h7 their first rookie 7 first was better
you're right partner the c4 pawn was
hanging so you could just skip the
bishop there what's hanging wonders the
Brooke oh my gosh oh my gosh we have a
Tigers hidings two back-to-back blunders
and that was a fi I'd match two games
won back-to-back camera can hardly
contain his nerves so what happens now
[Music]
and the 2018 speed Chess Championship is
kicking off with an event that's the
first of its kind with me although you
can't see them quite yet grandmaster
robert hess we have four players that
are throwing down today robert and this
is like this is you get three speed
chess matches in one day this is like
Christmas in June hi Robert you ready
hey Danny of course I am and if you say
you know we get some of us have to work
for the next six hours so we'll be a
tough task for us but we're here and
happy to provide the entertainment Danny
I mean you have four great players
everyone in the chest community knows
them what are you expecting for today's
action well as we take a look as
everyone can see who these four players
are these are household names on chess
comm and really to the entire chess
world to start off we have well let's
talk a little bit about the format we
have the foresee taken on the one seed
based on chess calm ratings that's
actually Grandmaster Eric Hanson the
chess brah played his way to the top
seed despite taking the thrashing from a
grandmaster Wesley so middle of last
week sorry Eric had to throw that out
there he meant he managed to get himself
back to the top he's taken on yellow big
hammer after that we're gonna have
Dominguez Perez taking on Georg Meier
they are competing for cash prizes that
will increase throughout the day with
the support of the twitch community
that's kind of a new twist we have for
this year's SCC fans can donate for
sweet tactics or their favorite player
or whatever they're into but the
ultimate price of course is that they're
playing to fill out this bracket right
here as you see who's who list of all
the best chess players on the planet
that have already confirmed their
participation in this year's speech
Chess Championship they're there they're
competing these four people are
competing for the for the spot to play
in the main event and as we can see our
two guys that are ready to kick off
first are sitting in their chairs and
they are ready to rock I'm gonna go
ahead and give the go-ahead to our team
that let's go ahead and start it and
we'll talk a little bit more about the
format as it gets going Robert and maybe
remind everybody what it is but given
that we're running a few minutes behind
I know these guys are anxious to start
playing it's game time you ready
absolutely it looks like Hansen has
finally played the first move of the mad
efore and danny you know i have to say
that i mean this is a close match for
sure because hammer and hanson they both
similarly rated in classical chess but
over the chest comp server i gotta give
the nod to Hanson right he's got the
whole chess bro community buzzing he's
been playing so much in recent years on
the server and well look at the rating
differential just in this game here it
looks like hammers 2647 and hanson 2883
well you know you're not necessarily in
the minority with that pick and it's not
of course to pick on our boy Yann Lud
big hammer who has a huge fan base of
his own in his own twitch channel if
you're wondering everybody you can go to
twitch.tv slash GM jlh but you know he's
I think he's the four seed for a reason
I think of the four players in the
bracket a lot of people feel like he is
the biggest underdog and that Eric
Hanson while he'll have his work cut out
for him surely against hammer is the big
favorite because of the things you
highlighted right he plays on chess calm
Blitzen bullet at the highest level and
his rating the the matchup on paper is
is what it is for a reason here yeah and
it's interesting is you know we'll get
to the actual chessboard in a second but
it's interesting because Dominguez and
Meier are the two highest rated players
in the field in terms of feed a rated
chess but yet they are the two and three
seats while Hanson is far and away the
most frequent actually I don't want to
say that all Myers in playing a ton of
chess calm so you know for those who are
you have been keeping an eye on and both
those players are very active as well as
hammer and Dominguez is more of the wild
card in that sense because he's not
nearly as regular on the chess like I'm
server well we'll see what is in store
here the players are right now just
completely focused on their games both
of these guys I know from talking to
them very excited for the opportunity to
qualify for the speeches championship
they've washed it and been fans like the
rest of us for the last couple of years
when you see the best players and we'll
play this format so they are both really
really excited about the opportunity and
as you can see there we will keep track
of the score between between these
players remind you that the four men in
this qualifier is a little different
than what you're used to where the
players are running and competing
against a running clock here there is a
set number of games per segment and they
are competing to basically erase the
first one to get to ten and a half
points given that there are five games
in the five plus one segment five games
in the three plus one and then ten games
of bullet total to decide who of these
four players is the best at in this mini
speeches championship format and earn
their right to the main event so that's
the prize fund that started out here
from chess comm it's 1,500 on the day
but we're excited for the opportunity
for the fans if you're interested in
helping to support these chess players
everything donated today goes directly
to the players nobody else and so you
are you are contributing right to their
pocketbooks if you see something you
like so all right Robert it was a a Rui
Lopez turned into some sort of Italian
structure what do you got here for us
well the first thing I would notice in a
position like this Danny is the bishop
um p3 is excellent it stairs down
immediately the knight on d5 but through
it the pawn on f7 and you see a hammer
retreat Knight of six a big problem was
Bishop to e6 was always hanging in that
pawn on e5 right because you block the
rooks protection the e5 pawn so Knight
f6
actually the retreat now allows the move
Bishop e6 to be played since the bishop
can capture on b3 is an intermediate
move and the Queen will be hanging on d1
so it's not like it was another move
right now
Bishop e6 would be a perfectly
reasonably shot so Korea for played to
challenge black on the Queen side now
and well before I mean this is somatic
and now a5 so he's using the a
Foursquare for the Bishop of the near
future and that will put further
pressure on the pony five yeah it's sort
of a typical way that you handled this
Queen side structure for white to play a
four and then counteract b4 with a five
as you said it opens up a four also make
sure that this pawn on a six might be a
long-term target for white to gang up on
and based on what I've seen on the clock
so far Robert and on the board feels
like Eric is a little more comfortable
here shout out to our last subscriber at
the twitch TV slash chess channel thanks
to everybody who's with us here hanging
out in the chat at both twitch and chest
comm TV if I miss your username it's not
because I don't love you I'm just doing
our best to folk
on the chest okay he goes to sea for
rather than a for does he want to put
the Queen there what's his idea now
yeah his Queen cannot go to be three or
a four depending on circumstance you
know for that's why hammer is not taking
on c3 you're leaving the tension there
because if you do take on c3 then a
white piece will come into the B file
with a tempo and that Bishop on b7 so
you leave the pawn there for as mister
as long as possible for a while because
it's not like why is ever gonna take on
before and shadow his own pawn structure
so now hammer can play move like rook a
to d8 but that d3 pawn is extra well
defended because the bishop on c4 cannot
be kicked off at diagonal so I think for
a Hanson moves like in the future like
Queen a4 just developing this Bishop
maybe to d2 to try to clarify what's
happening on the Queen side and from
hammers perspective you really have to
figure out how to configure your pieces
better because the knight on c6 cannot
move as the e5 pawn needs defending the
official mb7 will not have any life
until that night at Sussex does move and
there are no clear targets to attack for
the time being so I am definitely
favoring Hansen's position I would start
with a move like Queen to 8:4 here okay
all right so the rook goes to b8 last I
guess you're just preparing for the
opportunity that some action might
happen over here on the B file but okay
so Hanson switching gears slightly maybe
poking at the a6 pawn indirectly right
now it is a potential weakness but also
doubling his efforts on e5 but here
comes Bishop c5 Queen e2 is a little
awkward right because now aren't there
tactical opportunities for black at some
point you got to be thinking if you can
try to open up the Bhishma b7 and try to
get Eve four okay but Erik puts the stop
on that right away with this trade yeah
and now he spies in the a6 pawn right
actually in fact you can I wonder if he
ever just either missed that or has
something in mind cuz we were
highlighting that a6 was a weakness here
for awhile and Queen e2 did exactly that
I think era can just gobble that thing
yeah I'm not really sure how hammer is
gonna compete with just the simple
Bishop takes a six I don't see any taxes
whatsoever e4 is extremely well defended
I mean no pawns new week up that's a
free pawn which it takes a six so yeah
he takes it he was Lee
and smarter chess just donated five
dollars we appreciate that we will keep
track and try to keep you updated on
what the running prize fund is today
currently there they've put five bucks
in their pocket for the positional
technique to take care of a week a six
pawn Robert that's what a positional
that's what positional technique will
get you five bucks well you know for
Hanson to finish this went off he needs
to make use of that extra pawn an
outside pass pawn though it's not
actually easy to push right because the
a7 score is extremely well defended now
black is getting some activity on the
Queen side in the form of rook disrupted
b3 the other working them to a a to
attack that a pawn so definitely clear
advantage for Hanson but not the
cleanest position that you would like if
you have the white pieces here so I
think that the chances are pretty decent
for hammer to come back in this game and
try to hold a half point because let's
say Knight b8 here can I just keep
chasing this a pawn yes you will
well he's not he's not actually
threatening anything yet if he does
right white still has double the defense
that that he needs right now but okay
but no you're right though I mean hammer
taking a really solid approach Bishop to
b6 he's just gonna sort of strangle the
pawn and make sure that it doesn't
amount to anything yeah now Knight a5
then I could come to c4 yeah sort of
typical Queen side compensation for a
pawn you see this and a lot in certain
Grune fell type positions where white
takes the pawn on c5 and it takes a pawn
on b6 and black plays eight takes b6 you
just have give white an extra pawn and
black does have activity on it as the
compensation now this was not
intentional it's not like hammer was
like oh I'm gonna give up this pawn and
get activity now he blender let's be
real no I think he did but you you
highlight it well but look how
comfortable he's been since then I mean
the time on the clock says how
comfortable he is he went from being
down 90 seconds to to up 30 as they as
they crossed the one-minute threshold
yeah it's one of the frustrating things
in chess is when you go up a pawn and
you're still not clearly like you know
much much better
it didn't requires you to take some time
to come up with a winning plan and for
Hanson now were k4 seems to be wise okay
by quitting d3
I think Knight a5 will be met
but I think he's I think he's preparing
an idea of Queen d5 because if you can
open up the e file and the e pawn
immediately becomes a target maybe he
creates counterplay while black is busy
gobbling up to say six gold right yeah
blood can go right after there's rook
takes 86 is in fact the threat because
Queen takes a sexist met but Bishop
takes F to accept Bishop e3 stops that
plan in its tracks Thank You J clones
for the shout out there nice commentary
nice match appreciate your support and
thank you everybody
active on both both chat rooms and then
thank you everybody for being here as we
kick off the SCC yeah so hammer Queen c4
here if I'm Hansen I'm considering
several moves one is Knight takes e5 but
now a lot of trades will happen so Queen
d3 Knight takes D 353 yeah I can night
before trying to hold the pawn for one
more moment but feels like black is on
pace to to have defended himself to a
draw here I'm having a hard time
believing that whites are really gonna
hold on to this a six point well
actually now rook to be one can you play
the night followed the night d5 and the
b6 pawn Falls it may be knight c6 was
even better the last move okay but he
plays it now okay so I feel like I was
looking at a game recently with this
exact endgame it might even Wang Shao
playing with the white pieces and he won
this end gaming as wife really quickly
with with white it should not be that
easy to win but you know especially with
Knights and the board rather than
bishops oftentimes that extra pawn comes
in extremely handy and now the f5 score
is now post rook to d1 can come next and
rook is trying to aim its way to d6 if
you're black here what's the correct
defensive setup you need to defend your
king cuz 95 rip d6 check f6 I need to
get my white knees get the rook to 7th
rank then to go to g7 or at least make
an attempt to do so but at the same time
now black clearly has good chances to
make a perpetual via the a1 squared
Knight f3
but there goes the f6 bond I mean 95
next
that's a winning it's amazing I mean
we've talked about this before and I
guess we've posted so many shows
together but the nights really are the
best at winning winning these types of
end games where all things are equal on
one side of the board their ability to
maneuver and hop in and out you see that
sometimes I think people take for
granted that oh you only have one ponder
Brook endings are always drawn Bishop
endings are always drawn but Knight
endings really offer a lot of winning
chances as we see here yep and look at
the time situation Hanson just down to
three point eight seconds hammered down
to five and under so this is actually
it's gonna be a little bullet battle
here and if you're it takes h5o we found
it with Knight bowing and he found it
seven seconds left
now Hanson this is this is a Hanson
special here he's been in this situation
so many times living off the increment
of course every every game every match
is different but this is exactly where
Hanson thrives and as we can see brings
down the fork
let's get that fork emo going for all of
our twitch TV slash chess subscribers
all the subs that's that's how Hanson
Forks right there just brought strong
works that was honestly a very
impressive finish that game because for
a while looked unclear how he would make
progress he put his rook on b1 took him
b6 and said you know what I'll go up a
different pawn it may not be a past one
but I'm gonna make use of my extra guy
and turn it into a victory so very
impressive star for Hanson not a good
start for hammered not just because of
the the results of the game but I think
the way that game happened it was clear
that Hanson was better from start to
finish
hammer did try his best but he wasn't up
to the task and now with the white
pieces hammer really needs to make
something here because I think in the
bullet portion that is where Hanson's
biggest advantages yep and so as we get
these five games in the five minutes and
five games in the three minute
eventually those 10 games in the bullet
I really feel like will make a
difference in this match in Hanson's
favor no you're right and you know
that's one of the issues of being the
underdog is I think people could
probably make a case that Hanson is the
favorite and every time control and you
know but obviously in Bullitt where we
know that Eric Hanson really really
thrives and has and has played matches
against you know Nakamura even if he
gets adopted from time to time
and and guys like magnus carlsen so I
agree hammer has something to prove here
in this game he really really got it
taken to him with the black pieces but
now he has white and here he's a little
better right space advantage okay it's a
typical type of structure but I feel
like I feel like black is a a little bit
worse here with white space advantage
you agree yeah these compositions can be
very frustrating for black but I know
that very very strong players do play
this opening from the black side so it's
not like this is unheard of why I don't
like blacks Bush and German speaking
suspicions 1e 7 it's just stuck behind a
wall of pawns look at all of White's
pawns they're on the dark squares and
the kind of the backward pawn and the
chain is the one on d4 but it's
impossible for the time being to really
apply pressure that said Hanson has
taken a pretty great approach to this
and he's trying to trade off all the
pieces if he goes a takes before and
trade off the rooks for example how is
white gonna attack anything in the
position this is why I was getting to
the point B 5 is generally speaking
necessity but as Hanson shows you can
just retreat you can say if b c6 queen
c6 i'll take on c5 next we're trading a
bunch of pawns on the Queen side and
black should not be doing poorly here at
all you might want to start with Knight
b5 and then take the pawn 86 and play a4
but if I'm black I'm gonna play rook to
b7 and after C takes b6 I'm going to
take with my knight and that way a for
stop because I'm gonna take on a for my
knight can go into c4 in the near future
as well I I think black is perfectly
okay here sorry was I was kind of zone
it out it was a teaching moment by Bobby
Hess whatever happen go but no you're
right I guess I got a little excited at
space advantage but as we learned it's
not the space that counts but how you
use it once again we're reminded of that
lesson here as hammers space advantages
undermine deny and I agree with you then
when we look at it the board feels like
black is slowly unwinding he's a little
afraid to take with the knight here
Robert I think because of the move 95
was coming perhaps so he does settle on
taking with the Queen but Black has
gotten through
the worst of it I agree yeah look at the
squares for the black pieces now II for
for the night before for the bishop okay
there's a night that is cemented in the
d5 square for white which is a very
pretty piece but it doesn't actually do
too much from the time being if I'm
hammer I would like to actually double
in the C file and maybe try to put a
rook on c7 I also will consider trying
to play for f4 f4 to f5 to chisel at the
black pawn structure but here he goes
rook c2 next move rook to c1 and black
get to take care of his back rank you
know once the rope comes to c1 now the
c6 square of course is a place where I
want to land my rook so the control of
the C file actually is the biggest plus
in the position yeah for hammer and in
fact he's his advantage I believe is
growing and with that knight on d5 and a
2 minute almost 2 minute time advantage
to go with it he seems like he
anticipated the way the trades and the
way the Queen side opened up well yeah I
feel like every time I agree with you
that somebody's better you flipped the
script on me and then I agree with you
the other way I'm gonna start thinking
for myself Robert well I just think they
don't let you think for me anymore
yeah I really think that Eric's have
taken on b6 with a knight and then after
95 retreated his queen to e8 yeah you
give wet a little bit space for the time
being but white needs to figure out what
to do with the knight on d5 since the
palm was on 8th for yet so right it's
you know a little bit in the past now
especially considering no but I'm
showing the analysis there just to
highlight for the fans what you were
talking about because I think that
preventing white from getting this
cemented knight on b5 was really
critical and now that in the live
position as we can see here to our left
white not only has the 95 but control
over the only open file on the C file I
agree that it's it's now that the upper
hand is belonging again to hammer so
perhaps we were right that Hansen
undermined the space advantage well but
a miscue there and now he's now he's on
his heels
hammer hammers position is looking
better and better yeah this is looking
great for white because it's not like
black can ever kick this Knight from e 5
f6 you just you said you give away the
e6 bond so you can't kick it what is all
the space but if your hammer here you to
figure out how to actually land some
sort of knock out blow the rook on b7
that's great to cover this up Frank
night on e 8 now covers the c7 square
which could have been used by the Brooke
if you play rook c7 into the tech they
have seven pawn so native to figure out
how their pieces are pretty much
optimally placed how to actually land
something that is close to a knockout
blow so here in G for ya Queens you for
maybe five
yeah starts to prepare for that knockout
blow you're saying f5 would not only
create new ways for the Queen to get in
everybody but opens up the sixth-ranked
and watch out for that rook on c6 to
maybe have some tactics against against
the Kings side before it's all done and
you highlighted that there's no real
knockout blow for for hammer here Robert
but it's hard to find useful moves if
you're handsome right from the other
perspective and what what does black do
here that doesn't do this position worse
yeah I'm trying to play a move like
Knight to d6 but then I'm immediately
concerned about just for starters ideas
like Knight to c7 because now I'm
throwing Knight takes c6 and just
shattering open the black King side so
it's yeah it's not looking particularly
good here rook takes a six of course is
another stain dick keep an eye on
because if rook takes c6 then F takes c6
Queen takes d6 check yeah if the King
goes h8 Knight g6 check happens and that
should be that could be a fun tactic if
it ends that way I think right now with
the rook guarding the seventh rank is
it's not a direct threat I mean
something like let's say there's a
random move if hammer went for this I
think can black just play King h7 and so
it's just a game of tickle at this point
but yeah that's a nice tactic to watch
out for
yeah 694 okay here comes that five
though I think I think what's gonna
shoot moves here maybe maybe you
consider Brooke c7 as well as f5 okay he
goes for a5 and we start to see tactics
happening yeah because Knight g5 simply
Queen to g4 and just continue protecting
the f5 or the queen bee of e3 was
possible now black can consider Queen
now Queen g5 should not be good but okay
you played it I mean I'm thinking we
trade the Queen's right even if white
accepts
wait doesn't have to but if we trade
Queens and g5 then at least you have the
Queen's off the board
the control over the C file exactly rook
c8 you can take take up a knight c6 yeah
there you go
no Brooks the acres 97 discover check at
the end of that line exactly so I think
take take knight c6 is a pretty terrible
for block until rook e8 to protect the
85 pawn let's say but then Knight c7
comes and let's show that line takes
takes knight c6 everything buddy the
point is rook c8 would allow a
discovered attack so Brooke a 8 runs in
an IC 7 and probably hammer is just
those Knights those Knights have gone
wild
somebody let the dogs out and probably
white should win this endgame with all
things with with accurate play here and
hammer is still up more than a minute on
time so you don't want to do a time
scramble against Eric Hanson and that's
a pretty obvious but if you're winning
it's a lot easier to play any chess
position yeah I think he is he's going
for ya the 7th ranked I was gonna say
he's just trying to get the 7th rank
under control and play rook d7 here I
was gonna say Brook d7 because at least
it hits the D pawn but okay the rook d8
will come yeah so either way you're
gonna follow my rook around but I think
of it if I go rook to b7 and then you go
over b8 I can take on b8 you rooks on
the maybe a less helpful square for the
defense rook d7 any plates of clearly
what am I talking about yes sort of sort
of the same idea I think he'll probably
mean rook e8 but I just bring in the
other rook in Hanson doing the right
thing here everybody whenever you're in
this type of endgame we've all been
there you want to look for that
opportunity to just get active totally
willing to sacrifice this d5 pawn just
so that black can start to get the rooks
active against the white King and get
your own counter play going on the
second-ranked kind of a different you
got to be active you don't want to just
defend passively and get strangled yeah
and here I mean black for sure is
getting string on Knight c7 is an option
the issue with 97 is you're not actually
threatening the rook on e85 97 there it
is I mean rookie 7 by Knight East 6
check which is devastating winning in
exchange
but after Knight c7 I'm thinking can
read me black just move king - yep
there's king over cuz I was about to say
it and what do I do with my rook on c1
f 3 so what a night D to hear a 392 king
of two I guess hammer is life just I
wanted to go Knight c4 but I can't
because then you take my rook on y8
uh-huh and play Knight b3
yeah Knight b3 then I guess just rook
b1 and I'm attacking me eight rook and
your night on b3 at the same time so
it's Hansen zoned in here you can say
Knight takes d5 Knight takes d5 is a
tactic that works as both rooks are
younger it's I don't know I was gonna
say you can see hammers eyes going on my
lemon and I think he's calculating
Knight takes d5 right now yes I'm not
sure I love it though hassey guys making
n game they're 95 you go rook takes c1
okay it's a Cundy he just doesn't want
to give up any squares and not a knight
back to b5 let's say or the 94 wait a
second if anything he's gonna be missing
his opportunities here shortly look at
g4 trying to pry open the e4 square for
a fork sneaky little Hansen trying to
come up with tactic well both players
get under time pressure
well now rook d7 though is super strong
rook d7 90 days 96 first but look out
for rook d7 but now rook c2 maybe
yep just to get some nice t4 check ideas
I was gonna say even rook d7 might have
been possible there anyway but he needs
to just go for it yeah but now why is
White's too fast here yeah too fast this
discovered check is is really nothing
more than a bluff short of a blunder by
hammer so I think I think he's gonna
level the match here see he wants to
roof takes f6 obviously I'm maybe four
just gotta be careful okay so Brooke g7
throw that okay I read that check and
this movie rook it's a safety we're
nothing wrong with playing tickle
everybody especially if you have a 1
second increment discipline chest you
don't don't need to force it gained a
little bit of time on the clock there so
both sides are sort of playing this
oddly never work take say for the hand
to play 0.7 left you must flag he did
flag okay he did fly wow that's shocking
this not every day you see Hanson flag
when he's not playing her car Nakamura
but indeed he did there and we are
instantly off to see the the wizard
again and and the scoreboard has been
brought to level the prize fund is $10
more than what we started with I want to
give a shout out to all 2800 of you
watching this show right now I'm sure
there will be more as the day goes on we
have got a long day ahead of us right
after this Georg Meier has taken on
linear Dominguez Perez and then the
winner of both of these matches will
play later on today so Robert I'm
exhausted already and we just got here
this is this is gonna be it's gonna be
quite today yeah but it's an exciting
one because with all the Chesbrough fans
out there
the hammertime fans that have been
talking to Chad I've been looking
through the chat and I see verts which
saying hammers a champion what is hammer
a champion a champion so we got a clear
hammer fan in the audience on the twitch
chat and you know it's gonna be
interesting because Eric can go on tilt
you know as much respect as I have for
him as an a tremendous player he
sometimes does go on tilts he admits it
himself
right and you know here with the white
pieces he's better again they've got
more space things have been Pleasant in
the opening this far but I really think
that he has to be under control in this
match because you know he is the
favorite I mean there's no doubt about
it by the time we get to the bullet
portion of the game he'll make his
prowess very clear but for the time
being you can't start losing the 5
minute or 3-minute games because you
don't want to go into the bullet with a
deficit so right now I think but the
white pieces just continue playing
calmly solidly he's gonna play Knight d2
played only 4 if h6 well then I'll just
bring his Knight back teeth for right
away
and he seems to be doing quite well with
the structure so Bishop g4 don't know if
that really helps
hammer at all here because now then I
was gonna be my knight back to e for
anyway so is there some sort of
advantage of kicking the Queen to g3
aren't you supposed to know the answer
to that yeah okay yeah I don't know but
I you know you said a lot there I do
agree that that Eric has you know if he
has two things about his game that even
all of his chest bra fans know are his
weaknesses
sometimes he can manage he can manage
himself into time pressure okay
everybody
time pressure when they play hikaru and
Magnus and those guys but but we know
that Eric when he's on till can
sometimes start to for lack of a better
way to put it beat himself so I agree
with you that's the number one thing
here in this kind of format we know that
sometimes you know it's the emotions can
get away from you but but I think it I
think right here he's once again got
himself on the white side of this Lopez
turned whatever you want to call this
structure I keep calling it an Italian
structure but I feel like he knows these
positions well and and again we see him
up a minute and a half on the clock here
so just like Game one I feel like he
really knows his stuff in this position
yeah and these openings are pretty easy
to play quickly actually for them from
the white side you always in a slightly
better position blacks pieces can be a
little awkward you know now this night
can choose is one go to f3 doesn't want
to go to c4 you know he played before so
clearly he's nice not going to c4 but he
just needs a little bit of pressure and
blacks pieces giving me a little bit
more passive note to the b4 c3b to pawn
structure really limits blacks pieces
the michelin f8 is sort of staring into
that pond
what's this Knight goes to c6 opponents
g3 dominate tonight on c6 right that's
sort of a well known structural tidbit
that naive of c6 is often duck made by
opponents III because it covers it jumps
forward and now look at Hansen go just
pressing forward on the king said I
could put H five night h4 bring this
Knight to f5 V so chooses no weaknesses
in this position if I'm hammer I'm
trying to play moves like Knight f7 rook
da trip d7 and just take over the D file
h5 ok no fear yeah I was gonna say
that's a that's a weakness there I guess
white doesn't have a LightSquared bishop
or an easy Avenue to go target it but
that's something you really I'm nervous
and I'm not playing I mean this is this
is scary for black to have so willingly
opened up his King side here and here
yes here goes Hansen he's maneuvering
his way to go target that pawn g6 is
pretty much forced are we gonna see g4
is he gonna go I was thinking about that
what if g4 h takes g4 Knight takes d4 f5
comes in and all of a sudden I think
black is the one with a stronger attack
than white because he'd spent some time
moving your knight away from the attack
and then f4 can come at some point and
you know if the G file opens of course
what I'll make black will make use of
that so he's playing for the D file now
and maybe there was a good decision by
hammer after all to plays h5 move just
stopping White's progress yeah and from
blacks point of view you can play Bishop
h6 alright now you can just probably
trade on c5 interesting move though
because if the pawn comes there it sort
of continues to keep that night on f7 at
base so so hammer doesn't like it takes
over the diagonal that white left behind
I agree with you that I mean I was super
nervous when when hammer took this
approach but the more it goes on feels
like hammer is kind of slowly unwinding
here yeah now Henry Queen b3 and whites
attack is gone and suddenly you're
worried about infiltrations to the d2
square you're worried about the the bee
pollen being weak so I don't know about
Knight of three I think g4 was well
timed at this moment when the Queen went
to b3 that's the moment I want to go g4
and by playing g4 I'm attacking the pawn
h5 directly and you can't actually
defend it so the only way to defend is
by capturing on g4 the night takes g4
happens you have to spend a move playing
move like Bishop g7 and then why can't
even consider playing h5 they're a
temporary pawn sacked and bring my
knight to e3 and then try to take on h5
with the Queen so that was certainly in
the cards there I'm boiling your
variations on the analysis board did you
eat your Wheaties today nobody had a
Subway sandwich before that was that's a
shout-out for Subway that was a surgical
attack there by you buddy that was good
stuff I I agree with you liquid egg
product just donated $25 previously we
had Shawn username on Twitch donate $25
everybody that has been getting on this
train showing these players your support
for their chests and all the subs and
everybody's sorry that Robert and I are
so zoned in here focused on the chest
but I see everybody and shout out
nothing but love and with you all these
events happen so thank you for for being
here yeah absolutely
I will definitely be a better look out
for the chats but it seems like we have
a huge audience everyone seems happy and
it's actually kind of tense of the chat
I feel like because normally we have
people going crazy and just happy for
Hansen but I think they're a little
worried about him
for right now that's sort of the tone of
the chat so far because obviously the
yeah I mean the chest bra fanbase is
strong but uh but you know I know a
hammers got a huge fan base - right so
it'll be interesting to see that if this
was a close match down the stretch you
know who brings out there their flying
colors
yeah and in this current game look at
the white rooks an a1 and b1 I don't
think that's the ideal setup if you're
white and I understand why Eric did it
he wanted to play rook a3 and just kick
this Queen away and then try to you know
make progress on one side of the board
but now black has full control of the D
file it's not that important with the
knight on f3 it covers the D 2 square
but now look at my to a3 Brooke it's
about to go to a7 and start reading some
havoc on the Queen side so I'm not sure
if I'm loving the last bunch of moves
from blacks perspective things seem to
have gone worse for him I'm gues queen
c6 here and just try to trade the
Queen's off makes sense but then why
does the one who controls the D file so
you could play Queen takes c6 rook takes
c6 rook b3 first and work to D 1 and
just take over yeah here he goes for K 7
now you can't play rook to d1 that's a
big difference this rook d1 here can't
happen because b2 is hanging so look at
hammer just striking back immediate in
the center the knight on f3 is a bit
limited by blacks Fishman h6 plane efore
would be soon but yeah you don't want
yeah you don't wanna go to the deep for
it although actually now you can play
before then c5 and just continue playing
like that so I'm starting to like blacks
position rook d8 obviously kind of
prepares the idea of getting rid of the
knight everybody you've got your eyes
set on this D 2 square but c5 now just
gonna say yeah c5 and then just bring
bring the noise to the second rank here
actually I think if you even do it in a
forcing way you could you know you have
efore first and then c5 because it comes
with a temple in the night so that was
an idea as well I think it's a bit
concerned with playing c5 too soon
because after B takes d5 maybe there's
some pawn see six sacrifices know that
one of the rooks comes to a6 and you
know kind of pester as the black King
but now White's rooks have been taking
over the space and now c5 not possible
because the rook just came to a5 yeah he
for is not as good anymore because the
knight would come to d4 and then f5 is
under fire so so this rook a fiber very
strong yeah and now rook a3 will be met
by Bishop c1 forcing the rook to be
three so that's always a an option here
seems likely that sorry good night why
not Knight okay 90 xe5 feels too rookie
six okay yeah the pin I was looking at
Knight takes e5 and and the Brooke
couldn't do anything else because of the
for coming to d7 but White has to be
calculating some option where you go
after this e5 pawn right what about I
was gonna say what if Brooke takes e5
rook takes c3 and then the other rook
coming back to a5 hitting the f5 pawn I
wonder if that was an idea well it's
actually very interesting but loses
rooks eformula trying to go rookie for
Jeff also allows you know if I'm black I
actually really wanna play Bishop f4 um
now I can't do that yeah like II four
and Bishop to e5 I'll just rewrite the
bishops the e5 square there we go
the c5 move comes in does 92 trap know
there's a bishop on aged six to almost
trap said look King d3 might do the
trick though King Geoffrey teen d3 pawn
takes before right there's just in time
okay
rookie four is also still possible there
and c4 check might follow so King g3 not
as good as first started as I first
thought it was so if you can't do any
sort of tactical tricks on this rook
then I think black is just doing totally
fine now because the rook on d6 is with
a Brit barrel down to the B 2 square c5
if you take us if I we just can always
take back on c5 at any moment I'll
probably roughly to check first
mentioned
but you can see Eric leaning in there
slightly frustrated as you can tell that
he just feels like he should have had
something more now both sides are under
time pressure I don't know about this
Brooks he's six women I get why he did
it I would have played rugby to check
and Bishop f8 trying to get my bishop
that c5 square here bring the night
around to see 2 and then d4 and then b5
hey what's what he just did why'd he do
this I don't know why I ever did this I
think he k even there maybe he should
have played for a4 but now just yet take
him be filed with the knight it protects
the C pawn he's gonna flag even he's
like game very long time black is yeah I
agree too I mean despite defending well
something he just couldn't handle the
time pressure made that move with 0.5 on
the clock and he's gonna flag 0.3 leave
and free moves but this ending is not
cover cage 6 rook h6h Vaughn Falls and
with it likely the game okay you can
play you can play tickle here for a
moment that's irritating actually for
white yeah that was a nice defensive
resource there actually by hammer cuz
the game is not over now and Hanson is
still Hansen's under time pressure too
yeah not even close over but both the
time trouble and the fact is only one
extra pawn and that's an H pawn that's
very useful but here comes the threat of
e3 that's why Hanson had to go back
everybody there's a threat but III ego
h6 and III h7 so he can he gets away
with it so go you should have done it
before oh we've lost on time no hammer
goes into the think tank and you can see
his frustration oh my you know what he
should have done Danny should have put
III before rocket with the King on f1
because after F takes III passed funky
for infiltration kills the cat I'm gonna
go back to that game on the analysis
board and show everybody exactly what
actually no this was the previous game
so the the position that that Robert has
is talking about right there at the end
super instructive for those who those
who want to improve their Brooke endings
right here it's a really good lesson of
how important the King activity is
versus versus really even sometimes
that's not even worth a pawn sacrifice
go ahead whatever just go he ran away I
guess he's the bath
ah well good timing for us because
Hamburg gains a little bit of time on
the clock shaking his head needs to let
it go as we know it can be really hard
to do that but maybe Eric's gonna help
him out here by getting himself under
time pressure anyway but III right here
everybody take a look at the analysis
board super instructive comment there by
Robert because the acti the activity the
king and the infiltration into the f3
square really would have saved this
position for black III takes King e4 and
actually black isn't even gonna come
close to losing this endgame with
control over the second-ranked constant
mating threats against the white King
that was a pretty instructive moment
there and so Wow the the match goes on
but this is this is where we start to
see who's really gonna hold themselves
together mentally emotionally throughout
the day right Robert you and I have
weave this in this isn't our first rodeo
as far as seeing what what the world's
best do in this type of format you don't
have any time to take a break to step
away to clear your head you have to
forget about it short-term memory loss
is the greatest gift here and if hammer
doesn't forget that loss it's gonna hurt
him throughout the rest of day
absolutely and here with the black
pieces Hanson knows his stuff you know
he obviously is down on the clock but
that's not because he's thinking in the
opening he just went to the bathroom it
seems and you know he's temporarily
giving away this d5 pawn but how do you
capture the capture with a knight on d5
I can just simply play Knight to c6 and
then I'm gonna take your d4 pawn pretty
much no matter what because you're in
pawn on key to is pinned to the Queen on
d1 and if you kick my bishop away it
takes the bishop on d5 but this is
riskier in fact because the bishop on d5
is out of it's fee in Quetta of you at
e3 here I think black can try eggs is
gonna say e5 and just sort of play for
activity you can't castle for the time
being for white because h3 pawn is now
under attack yep and so you're gonna
have to rely on the fact that you're a
pawn and even perhaps too if you decided
to take on b7 but it's very dangerous
very risky decision making Wow
he's all-in on this pawn grabbing affair
hammer is is gonna make handsome prove
it I mean Knight c4
for starters looks pretty decent attempt
to just take Gumby to next but there
probably something queen c8 is tempting
to hit the h3 pawn yeah it prevents
castling indirectly and and there he and
it it clears the d8 square and it
indirectly increases pressure against c3
so I like that movie yeah how is why can
a develop look at this bishop on c1 that
Bishop needs to get out somehow but it
can't move with the pond b2 hanging if
you played b3 while you just hang your
knight and open up this Bishop on g7 as
well so now if I'm Eric do I play rook
d8 first or he just decides to rip off
the h3 pawn makes perfect sense I don't
even see how white he's gonna even claim
an advantage here because now you still
can't move your beep on as my knight
discoveries well when you look on a1 now
I can take on g2 and play Knight C port
and your efore pawns hanging your B two
pawns hanging I mean where is what's
going on here where's the relief it's
not coming
Marty played Bishop g4 that was like he
wanted to induce f3 I think now you have
the darks where's tactical ideas at some
point he's uh
okay several moves here for black to
continue the pressure I mean you might
even just play something like Knight c4
right away and there are ideas like
Queen c5 check coming shout out to our
last set of subscribers and the the
cheers there thank you - thank you for
the bits from Lee Prince and all 3200 of
you tuning in to what is really the
season opener of the 2018 speed chess
championship today's all day knockout
qualifier to decide who gets the spot to
join the main event is is its opening
day you know I know Roberts a big
baseball fan so it's opening day don't
get me started about baseball Danny
oh you mean look at look at this thing
audiences and the crowds there's so few
spectators the game's just terrible what
we baseball here I don't know why you
had to go down that road but we can see
Eric is now either finding his feeling
his mojo or just trying to let the fans
know he's relaxed but he's been bobbing
his head here I think he's trying to
pump himself up because right now he's
down a pawn Knight f6 check could be an
annoying threat actually it's not really
about annoying because you take take and
play Bishop takes a two so hmm
okay maybe he's totally fine so Bishop
III from white threatens Knight c7 yeah
so Bishop III I guess rook or I take no
Queen takes a - actually yeah just go
pawn grabbing yeah I'm not really
feeling this position for white neither
is hammer he doesn't seem to be super
thrilled and feels like he was just sort
of out prepared in this light I mean he
went he went down the road of pawn
grabbing but has been regretting it ever
since
yeah this is uh
it's not ideal nicéphore even better I
think 97 not really possible everybody
because the night will take on e3 with
tempo on the Queen and even if it is a
big trade black will be much better in
the end because all of these bishops
will come to life and take everything on
the Queen side but that means if hammer
has to deal with the threat on e3 and
and still has problems with the a to
pawn it's looking more and more like
Hansen is about to take an early lead in
this match we'll have our first two-game
lead if it keeps this way well so I
guess a couple things here Bishop d4
it's a possibility but then I guess he
doesn't concern just the white bishop
lights corporation taking on d5 yep
so that's gonna be a nuisance so I said
Bishop no I know they take that in d5
right away I guess so Bishop takes d5
Bishop g7 Bishop takes e4 we're playing
well you also have 93 tricks Intermezzo
all over the place
ooh which is what I thought I thought
you were say yeah that's nasty yeah
there you go look at you busting out the
first honey badger reference of the day
somebody just lost a bet who would do
the first honey badger voice Danny or
Robert I think it was like probably 10
to 1 odds me all right he goes g7 I
think that Hansen is gonna pop a pony no
he doesn't put he doesn't go pony
popping take c4 well you know it's this
if he's cocaine takes g7 go 95 mean you
control all the dark squares I was
worried about okay I guess there are no
tactics as you said the knight
establishes itself on e5 the bishop on
g2 is hemmed in I know Queen b6 at any
moment and trade Queens a2 still hanging
oh this is terrible for white it's a
dark square clinic rook b3 now player up
e3 that way you can go Queen b6 next you
blockade the beet soup on and threaten
the g3 pawn huge shout out to sense HS
coming in with the biggest donation
we've had of the day increasing the
prize fund for these players up to 1590
we're about to cross the 1600 threshold
we got a long day ahead of us so thanks
to everybody for being here remember all
of your donations go directly to the
players and their prize fund not just
these two but also the next two super
grandmasters lined up Georg Meyer and
Elaine ER Dominguez Perez so
what is hammer doing because Queen b6
sort of yet oversee five rooks imago
rule 43 maybe you even have 93 oh no not
a 93 dog pin huh wake up Dani this is
hammer just lost upon both b2 and g3 are
hanging and that 95 is still a stud yeah
that's never frustrated you know if I if
I didn't know any better well I think I
do know better but I think I'm right
anyway I really feel like just watching
hammers body language and how quickly he
played this opening feel like that last
game really had a hangover effect and
now he needs to let go of it even more
so because if he loses this one and goes
down to games you got a rally quickly
everybody knows that Hansen is one of
the best in the world at bullet so
hammer needs to keep this thing close
yeah this is terrible for white I mean
Black is up upon great night terrible
Bishop and we might even get a mate to
go with it h5 followed by as Eric would
say some sort of penetration
coming in although h5 Bishop f3 will be
played now so at least even so if Bishop
of 3 the knight can move and yeah right
of 2 followed by rook t2 you should have
played f6 first I know been fine doses
never play f6 but at least you could
have cemented your night on the e5
square and then it's either f6 or even
King f6 I don't disagree maybe King of 6
is even better just to hold the knight
on e5 but I think either way black is
black is aggressively moving forward I
mean now okay even yeah 93 you're
threatening Brooke f2 to win the bishop
the night finds a new home 964 here it
doesn't matter well you know that's a
smart move there by Hansen because he's
just eliminating any outside chance he
loses this game at a time scramble
everybody I see what you did there
outside chance cousin outside pass pawn
Oh hashtag first awkward just punt of
the day ya know you know by getting rid
of the a pawn you ruin you ruin any last
hope white might have had it at swindle
in you or
we're using using this a pawn in some
sort of time scramble trick at this
point with all the pawns on one side of
the board
the knight is the better piece then the
bishop to be frank and and Europe upon
all ready to go with it so yeah but now
we Roxy sevens of threats a Bishop d5
here the night will come to d3 to e5
perfect timing
it finally makes its way back home the
knight will land on this perfect square
hammer shakes his head probably resigns
here if I had to guess
now hopefully I'm I never give up roll
up though he's gonna trade I don't know
that that really means that he gets a
draw but the King will just run too deep
d6 e5 but then we're hmm I don't know
have plainest f6 and g5 to hold okay I
thought he would play for g5 just to
hold the dark scores there but yeah Wow
did uh did hammer just swindle himself
this could be a huge emotional boost
especially if he if he holds on here
he's already I mean you can just sense
the change in their body language here
he's already feeling like he may have
gotten more drawing chances than he
deserved in this game but uh but will it
be enough to actually save the half
point I'm trying how he's gonna attempt
to win he's not the breeze King back
over to g5 like you said the King FAQ 7
King age 6 yeah then how do you kick the
king away from f4 you know the night is
the best piece in the time scramble for
some sort of swindle show in 95 in the
King G 593 check King III whoa oh he
commits to g5 that can't be the best for
blacks winning chances actually yeah it
is he's a go chief oh he could have went
he needs to go g4 King g5 and pawn h4
and just sort of like crashed through on
the the King side she what you're saying
g4 King g5 h for kind of forced your way
into a cheap on yeah it looks like
that's what he but now I do I need my
knight to be able to give a check so I
think he nobody was allowed King a5 he
did but hammer didn't take it
I can't a five case five yeah it King
tg4 it's gonna be a draw what sort oh my
gosh what a save
although one of them semi flags so yeah
nothing is nothing is over till it's
over but now you see the the opposite
and they're in their perspectives here
wow what is safe there no business
drawing that end game we were we were
about to to put Eric's technique on the
positional mantle right right next to
your trophy from t-ball but instead he
let it slip away and that's a win for
Norway I see axe villager putting the
Norwegian flag and I see virtue is
hammer time and a lot of people going
with the hammer time okay so maybe it's
not all chess brought fans in the chat
of course we see Tommy over there
holding down the chess bra he doesn't
know anything but chess bra hype so
thanks everybody who's here Thank You
chess Bay for all of your all of your
support and help as usual and the entire
chefs comm team behind the scenes here
thank you to everybody well it's maybe a
members on chess TV as well thank you
for being here is Hansen up a point
Hansen still up a point even with that
draw how do how did that happen because
Tamara was just white got it yeah yeah
Anton won both of his games at the white
pieces yep and he's got the same
structure here hammer playing a little
faster now as we can see not not down as
much time but you know we see both these
players having trouble for forgetting
the last game Hansen still frustrated
that he let that one get away but
there's plenty of time left for both
players to right the ship so okay what
can hammer do differently in this
structure let's put on Robert has his
teaching pants I don't if you brought
those did you leave your pants in the
dryer you got them on there actually at
the tailor they're being altered so like
you know knocking off the Matisse today
dispute Ricky just subscribed for you to
put on some of your teaching pants and
let's talk about it because how his
hammer gonna change his approach in this
structure so far he's been ground down a
couple times although that last one he
kind of held on and maybe now he has a
similar idea brought the night to
eight gonna rima new ver it to f7 so
that he has threats of coming to d6 what
can what can we tell the fans about this
position for for them to understand this
better yeah I think that hammer did a
very very good job last game he deserves
credit for it
he sort of blundered in the end game
when he was actually turning the tables
on Hansen and here Hansen has gone for a
different approach he said well look at
the a file I haven't overlooked on a one
that's on a semi-open file I'm gonna
start attacking some of these queenside
pawns and what he's done is tied this
night net down on d6 to the pawn v7 that
said the 96 also closes the D file so it
makes it hard for white to get any sort
of penetration on that line White's
plays pretty easy for a standard b6 at
some point will have to be considered
because the knight only has the c6
square to run to but in any comes with
you know the the weakening of the a six
point right so you have to be exactly
and actually once you a knight c6 you
but Queen d5 net oh okay he's in the
knight c6 Knight to c4 maybe but there's
some sort of tactic on nice e6 given
that it's undefended temporarily by the
Queen on e6 it makes you wonder if
that's what he's going for is okay yeah
here he goes he puts the knight on c4
which does two things
hits the night the e3 bishop and the BG
pawn so three things that's three things
yeah your counting skills were on
finding my counting skills were on fine
display as they pretty much always are
well here we can see him or laughing I'm
not sure if he just heard us I'm not
sure if he's listening
I don't even know I never recommend
listening to my banter while you play
but you know to each his own yeah and
the knight can just return to c4 I guess
but what Hanson's claiming is that once
he swings his rook to a1 he's gonna
double up on the a pawn regain it and
hopefully for his sake get an advantage
but I'm not so sure I think that even if
black goes back that pawn I'm not sure
White's any better there but let's see
nicéphore is played brook a1 and how do
I defend I can play pawn to a5 which is
encouraging a bunch of trades in the a5
square
but wait he's a little bit more pressure
a little bit better work activity a
stronger Bishop III compared to the
bishop on f8 so maybe that's a that's
slightly favorable for white you can
also just give up the pawn on the square
but for example Knight takes III pawn
takes c3 it's only White's position is
shattered by no means because at some
point you're gonna have to take on d5
you can just leave my queen there
forever once you take on d5 after each
65 my pawn structure fixes itself yeah
so hammer not interested in that he
agrees with you decides it's in his best
interest to just simplify it out he's
gonna lose the pawn back but Dani there
was a kind of crazy attack there was
Knight East 7 check and move there
Knight it's 7 check its my gosh he
missed it well then here King f7
actually so yearly the idea of my buddy
is Robert was disconnecting the Brooks
protection from the Queen and pointing
out that this rook can't leave the
eighth-ranked without a8 falling black
would be okay with King of 7 but that's
a nice nice find although didn't didn't
work anyway whether Erik saw it or not
he made the right decision and now you
said that at some point black would have
to take on d5 but hammers trying to
prove you wrong here forcing Erick to
move his queen
rather than trade and undo both the e
pawn so actually I'm liking hammers
chances a lot more now that he could
force that trade if he can get his
Bishop activated try to get use get some
play against these weak pawns I think
hammer has has played that transition to
the endgame wealth
oh absolutely look at this rook on d3
attacking both c3 and III there's no way
to defend both black is just better here
you come you know maybe Hansen will hold
this one because maybe I'll get his
Knight to a good square but no something
something happened here and it's one of
those things that is this game is more
important to the overall match score
then then maybe everybody realizes right
now because Eric has gone back to this
well in the Royal up has three times and
he won the first two so if hammers
persistence and stubbornness to keep
trying to find the right approach for
black pays off and forces Eric not to
play this opening look for that to play
a part because there's still a lot of
blitz
James left so obviously it's just one
game but if hammer has figured out the
right approach for for black in this
structure that's that's gonna pay
dividends later on right for sure I mean
Hanson will need to mix it up and will
by the time we get to bullet Hansel are
you playing any and everything I think
that's how you tend to play bullet at
these levels I know that's how I do it I
played b3 a lot but you know yeah
actually mix and match however I see fit
but in this current game Hanson is both
gonna be down a pond and he's down a mid
and a half on the clock so yeah things
are not looking good for him
rare rare for Eric to be down that much
time even with someone who occasionally
struggles with time pressure shout-out
to doctor who said ik one of the one of
the chests bras in the chat okay hammer
wins one pawn and it wasn't even the
weakest pawns on the board the e pawns
are still there so Hanson shaking his
head yeah I mean when Eric's trying to
do is wait for the pawn to go to c5 it
so he's really hoping for so he can
plant his knight on d5 he's an outpost
of some sort but with the pawn on c7 and
no direct access to the d5 square
because you can't go through III as a
pawn there that night on c4 would just
stay put and try to lay claim that it
actually stopped black from doing
anything look at this current setup here
the rook on c6 is actually completely
dominated by this knight on c4 and the
rook on a and I like what Eric's been
doing here he actually might want to
just throw his III pawn off the board
and play Knight e3 here yeah and and
then bring his knight to D or f5 but you
know concern deposit up there maybe just
continue flipping your rook back and
forth play keep them work on the a file
then you just don't let this work out
what is the rook gonna do just play rook
a to here sit relax and ask Hillary
beech sit relax and enjoy well if hammer
can wiggle his way out he is up the
extra C pawn but I agree with you look
at this really nice technique Eric takes
a way to be five square the knight is
working with him to guard the a5 Square
and hammer giving kind of a scowly face
they're not thrilled with his inability
to get that rook active how do you know
it you might have to play rook e6 Bishop
d6 there we go he goes for it
then maybe rook e8 maybe that's the way
out he finds it yeah but yeah bishop DA
he isn't to trade it off let's see
rook a7 at some point Ricky eight okay
rook a7 though I can go my knight to b6
with check and then over d5 but even so
that feels like progress for black as
long as he can as long as he can keep
the bishop in a position to guard the f6
pawn against the coming Knight to d5
if this rook gets out Black has winning
chances again yeah but I don't know
Brooke a6 check that I order waited to
play Brooke a6 and so the bishop was on
e7 so I would've started with a move
like King d3o if the bishop was on e7
you would have been able to bring it
over and pin it I see yeah my king yeah
keep marking off the dark square so
after king c6 back again I will play oh
his idea was a king b7 rook d6 maybe
well the other idea I was gonna say the
other idea is g4 and he plays rook c8
first but I was wondering if it was even
possible to play g4 and then rook g8 and
just aggressively look for more counter
play on the Kings side I like that a lot
yeah I actually really like it I wonder
if he I wonder if g4 was was a more
forcing way but Eric already in trouble
either way and now has to run back over
to try to defend so I'm not gonna lie to
you Danny I have a you know a tab open
with the World Cup and Messi Messi just
escorting also a shout-out for Messi
shoutout to shredder Roy who just
donated $25 and for those of you who are
just joining us the prize fund is spot
of course the base price fun part of
this features championship overall $1500
on the line just for today a lot more
than that overall throughout the the
next few months as you all watch every
single match we know you're planning
your schedule around it but the prize
fund on each given day is also
potentially bigger based on the fans and
and what they decide to give so shout
out to shredder Roy there and everybody
who's donated the the players here
hammer Hansen Meyer Dominguez Perez they
appreciate your love okay I think Hansen
is gonna be appreciating the rook ending
because okay six just play Brooke at six
I thought even flavor cage six - I think
I'm gonna say I think he has much better
drawing chances now yeah same idea that
Kirk f6 check King C for now
infiltration here he goes
so I would go c6 and I'm black play c6
King c5 rook checks three ways do you
even have time to do it I just play h3
the reason why that's good for black is
the White King needs to hide yeah I
started with h3 now King d5 the white
king hides on e5 Oh Ben didn't play C 5
c4 c3
oh and this nice so yeah I don't know if
Eric saw that it may have been losing
either way but that's a nice find by
hammer quickly yeah the problem is the
kit White King needs to stay behind
pawns cuz rook check and now the C pawn
just rules so now play King be a 7-bit
King everybody the rook checks typical
rook ending ideas you got to know that's
why the white king is imprisoned on the
e-file here and hammer is probably gonna
win because of it Wow hammer yeah
bronze it even so after a super tough
loss yep sorry then where they wants a
three minute I saw the game's start
already and I'm like wait what's going
on here they're now and we're instantly
in the next segment of today's match
everybody has a quick reminder the we
will move quickly from five minute to
three minute from three minute - one
minute and if I had told you to start
the day
partner that we would be tied hitting at
a three minute you buy that yeah I would
definitely bother I think the slower
time patrols favored a hammer not
favored him over Hansen but favor him
way more so than when he plays in the
bullet yeah I think if he needs to make
his his moves here in the longer time
controls and actually think that they're
relatively you know pretty level in the
slower games I know Hansen is a higher
rating and you showed great success here
in chess calm but hammer is a very good
player himself and I actually think the
fact that hammer typically places
openings very quickly which we're not
seeing in this game will help him in the
blitz segment but right now Eric playing
instantly he knows his
Grune felt type positions extremely well
and thus you know he's those two minutes
and almost 50 seconds in the clock
but now he's sitting in thinking after
94 so the idea is clear for him or
protect the defy upon what you play
Knight to d4 you open up this bishop on
g2 and from with the mission 1 G to open
you could play E for to further protect
the pawn on d5 then they don't a 5 is a
little bit awkward but it's gonna find
itself back in the game shortly with
moves like Knight to c4 and here can't
you just leave white with an isolated
pawns II d5 II d5 Knight a to c4 for
example bring this Knight to d6 black
lacks a bit of space which is the issue
well c6 I guess in that under before was
just hanging right I was gonna say the
other option is even c5 if you're
motivated to kick that night out but he
doesn't need to he just wants to take
advantage of the pin that he's got on d4
and now black won't win the pawn back
but b3 is an interesting move not just
because it takes away the squares we
said that's the that's that pony's
access point to get back but also
prepares Bishop a3 as well as Bishop b2
in some positions yeah I mean here at
Bishop III followed by Brooke c1 makes
perfect sense for a three-book c1 go for
a night b5 the pond d5 is actually easy
to target for the time being but
submission ether funny the wheat wood
I'm not sure that we would have
anticipated this right white was up a
pawn black struggling to get it back we
transitioned to a to a situation where
black holds the extra pawn but now it's
white with the pressure yeah I mean well
I don't know if I ever had an extra pawn
but we're definitely the more space and
even the extra pointed yeah yep on d5
wasn't extra but okay so now I may have
five perhaps heading to c7 I guess you
have to worry about d4 punching through
yeah I wonder at what point you want d4
to happen because then you could take on
c6 and try to take on d4 but there's
still a lot of dangerous options I mean
even if you play Knight b5 and d4
happens you could play Bishop before
and you still just have a ton of tactics
potentially over here with the knight
coming in okay we're going to find out
because that looks like where we're
headed well and Bishop takes c6 d 3f e3
I mean you you can get away with that
for the time being but it looks way too
awkward I'm out but it'd feel like
giving up the bishop pair submission of
four makes far more sense and a shout
out yesterday who just gifted her 64th
sub on our Channel
- agent jail and 64 that's a magical
chest number ya can't give him any more
Kenya yep that's it you're stuck at 64
unless your words know a four-player
Chester's well okay so yeah alright but
he goes for this Bishop a4 line as we
anticipated now even Bishop d6 fall of
like five yeah g5 super double-edged
super risky
can I go Knight c7 that's my first
instinct is like can my knight get fine
it's way back home if I go Knights e7
probably not nice e7 GF 498 I just you
know go Queen back to d8 for example and
I get straps maybe it wasn't possible
but this isn't this might be something
he regrets okay he could have also
considered Bishop a3 but then a6 would
have been really strong shadow tonight
hmm
library ladder just gifted a sub a kappa
blanka appreciate it I like to move
Danny Bishop e3 because Knight c7 comes
too deep because d5 through c7 so that
was definitely a possibility here on
Knight d6 Brooke e 7 it's like both
sides are kind of hanging on by a thread
and certain lines so now 96 yeah now 96
definitely 96 rookie 7 though then
Knight takes c8 I use go Brooke takes
the 8 back
you also have 94 with tempo possibly and
then you can try to get the knight it
try to get the bishop out to be 6 later
actually like that better yeah I was
trying to go tonight take CC 8 and then
if you take on c7 have Knight b6 and d5
right that right that much is clear but
if Knight see just rook c8 yeah you're
kind of my bish 1 c7 sort of
great squares yeah you could play Bishop
b6 as I'm showing any nails this board
and probably White's still okay but the
biggest issue right now is gonna prove
to be time hammer lower than 20 seconds
as we said the time controls are already
faster we are in the 3-1 portion of the
match today okay so just trade it on e 1
and play d3 at some point you might even
just play h6 okay he plays g4 to defend
it I was gonna say you might just take
your time to defend that potentially
loose pawn and then focus on moving the
D pawn after that it couldn't white have
just made a draw by gonna rough take c7
trading on e7 take on c6 and take on d4
is that like uh I guess you just take at
the policies no I'm speaking nonsense
I'm trying to win the d4 pawn back but
there's so many pieces defending it well
of the time situation all it's enhancing
down under fifth second one of the
things that that eric has a tendency to
do and he knows oh and he could be
critical of this in myself but right now
it's not gonna matter because he spots
the skewer that hammer didn't see Eric
does sometimes switch back into modes of
taking a little too much time and maybe
overthinking what he should do in a
position but right as I said that that
might matter it certainly did not and
Wow hammer and we're pretty frustrated
with that but but it's it's a match here
everybody if you're just joining us it's
only a one game separation even with
that victory by grandmaster Eric Hanson
taking the first point in the faster
time control the there's still plenty of
time left Hanson is favored and bullet
at least by most people's eyes and and
for a good reason but but right now
hammer has really been close in this
match despite being the underdog yeah
hammer rolled his eyes after that game
clearly upset with himself at how he
missed played the open and went down a
pawn and could never get quite enough
compensation for that pawn so clearly
ticked off hammer and for Hansen well
look what he did here he just
I'm gonna play this the boring Berlin
yeah the boy in Berlin with the rookie
one just trading off some pieces it's
slightly slightly better position and
he's trying to play like a super Jim at
a classical tournament and I think
that's the wrong approach look at the
time situation hammers you know has a
full time on the clock Eric's the one
who spent half a minute yeah and you
know I guess if you're hammer your work
with Carlson in the past not and your
commentary at big events and you're just
you know overall chess observance pays
off in the sense that you're not gonna
be worse in an equal position so yeah
not loving the opening choice yeah I
agree with you especially because of the
time and because of you highlighted one
of the key points of who hammer just is
it's even if this support of your
repertoire hammer has helped prepare
this many times as magma one of magnus
carlsen seconds and as a commentator
knows these positions pretty well so not
sure why he chose this well we'll
obviously talk to the players after the
match win or lose as we always do in the
speech Chess Championship and then see
if this was an opening or just kind of a
brain slip that Hansen didn't get a lot
out of this opening and now he's down a
whole minute yup and G moves name this
the super boring variation yeah so shout
out to everybody in the chat I see lots
of you here I see mr. wolf Hoover twitch
kappa blanka agent jail chess chess bay
from 94 of course lots of people here
rooting on the players and joined the
action unfortunately not much going on
here although I don't want to speak too
soon because sometimes what's tricky
about positions like this is you get
sort of relaxed and think the position
is so simple and that's when the
mistakes start to happen for example
rook to e8 here I will take on the 898
ton play Bishop h6 okay but Bishop b5 or
I was going to say was after Bishop h6
if you played Bishop g7 I have the move
Queen to e7 hitting your knight on the
8th you have to take my bishop on h6
and I think and then I go
we take CA followed by 95 stuff and I'm
getting a tremendous position I know
that was a lot direct analysis there but
the point is that you can't get to lakhs
in a position like this it is easy to so
it's debt equals boring etc when in
reality there are some some issues that
you have to solve for the black side
it's not super duper clear where it it's
just a dead draw that said it is a dead
draw if you play accurately and so just
do that and you'll be fine
yeah ahem we're still uh permitted on
the clock so whether whether Hanson
missed this Bishop h6 Trekker or didn't
think it was as much as we first thought
it's he did he it's still just a pretty
dead equal position that with before
time pressure sets in we'll see what
happens in time pressure and he that
happens that Bishop h6 move on us it was
a quite tempting in that position so
yeah yeah the time situation clearly
tremendous advantage for hammer now he's
the one trying to infiltrate with his
Queen if you're black spend a g7 here
and say they have nothing to worry about
yeah this is 7 yep I feel like if I'm
white here I'm trying to make a draw as
quickly as possible because just did you
just regret your opening decision you
didn't get anything time to just weasel
out right yeah and I feel like with the
white pieces you put pressure on
yourself to win games and this is not a
position where you can really win and
you make moves like c4 which are fine
but may and no I was just highlighting
maybe it's not that fine it creates the
only real pawn weakness we've had in the
game so far which is on d4 if black
plays 96 yep so no you it's almost like
you had a premonition there you know
pointing out that probably Eric should
just settle on what this game has truly
become which is just dead equality take
the draw now he plays c4 and instead as
what the white piece is thinking he
needs to win may end up regretting the
weakness he created I think black should
just play 96 here don't ya okay Wow
what what's he doing is he one as you
want queen chief or some sort of
trickiness I don't understand what
either player is doing honestly I know
you're you know you're paying me it's a
give you that information
I don't I think I'm just paying you in
chess boards today so I mean this is a
strange why is that my own h.5 I guess
that's an hom just stop white from
playing h5 but if you'd gone Knight f5
you'd have attacked the bishop on 86
also the d4 pawn I've been talking about
here for the last few moves so I still
like black let blacks chances here but
it is getting weirder
so queen g4 if C takes d5 Drive Bishop
f4 okay now Queens I think that's what
he wants look at the analysis board
everybody Queens you for say some sort
of move has played Bishop before us
coming in trapping the bishop on e6 and
if you take there's a fork on f4 so okay
hammer either doesn't see this or has
another idea in mind but now now that
deep on that was supposed to be a
weakness as a plot is a passer yeah
Queen e5 here okay so it takes takes now
Queen B five I think but then I can just
sit itself on e4 that's the big problem
for black is that yeah it's that comes
to eat for you can't go fi without
allowing Knight g5 check which is very
annoying and yet d6 coming soon yeah I'm
not liking blacks mission so much yes
somehow they he this whole plan with
Knight h5 I feel like maybe hammer saw
some some mating net tricks this night
h5 queen chief or they kind of you know
was speaking to him a little bit but he
he gave into temptation when he should
have just been solidly approaching the
weak deep on shout-out to library lad
coming through with yet another gifted
sub on the day appreciate that I'm
tempted by moves that don't work here
like g5 h6g 500 the g5 square did you
forget about that one so Knight takes a
seven is there 963 or something it's
getting crazy here Wow well though the
time situations I don't find out no he's
running the King Hamor shaking his head
and honestly as he should be because I
don't think that this is a g3 hammer
take Jeter only chance take g3
especially when he only has four seconds
he's gonna do it but he should tell him
to move on b5 b5 the tempo in the Queen
and it takes d5 check what's he thinking
when what what is he doing he's doing
the King but now now he soon has the
Queen in a better defensive spot so
crouch 1 shut yep h1 check whoa we need
to check King do you want Queen takes d5
and take on f7 other painting me there
they're physically hurting me right now
you're calculating faster than most
human beings can hand it should be sure
oh this is bad this is real bad he
doesn't have enough there's between if
you check taken up oh he takes a 4 he
had to go can't Adi ones that can eat
one with only 2 seconds on the clock
Hanson in a huge time scramble here
Queen III check he's gonna trade Queens
no then he loses a piece oh boy Wow okay
Bishop c7 or that just he's gonna get
rid of it play b5 gotta still be a draw
but blunder ville population population
our two players here and we'll back up
quickly and take a take a peek of what
just happened there but oMG that hammer
hammer had that one really once he made
that breakthrough there had to be a
window for black you called several of
them including that nice little that
nice little that check I'm gonna show
the fans here on the analysis board
camera shaking his head he's upset with
himself he's mumbling I can just see his
face mumbling things himself I don't
know what he's saying but but one of the
key moments before he even sacrificed
her before he sacrificed further right
in this position if he had played Queen
g2 check everybody the move that Robert
was calling for it forces the King to
the D file no matter what because
otherwise you lose the Queen so whether
the King goes to d3 or d1 then Roberts
idea was Queen takes d5 check followed
by Queen takes f7 but there was Queen to
d2 Robert which would appear prevented
right yeah I trade Queens I mean I can't
be you know I'm a I I don't feel it
you're right I mean you still there's
three points for the piece here and
black is the only one who can win but
but okay it was makes it a little bit
easier to swallow looking at that but
certainly black had
enough you would have thought to win
that position especially given that Eric
had about one second it's at one point
yep and now what is this last move here
Bishop e6 I think hammer is trying to
fear the same thing and there he's
shaking his head I think he just loses a
piece and what happens is your d5 here
yeah that's what I'm I didn't even
calculate whether he actually lost a
piece and I'm just saying the same thing
like that you must be losing a piece on
d5 oh wait a second d5 Knight oh no it
doesn't work no if he takes everybody
the point is among other things doesn't
white just have a for pinning the knight
to the Queen on d8 so hammer is gonna
take his time to make sure but yeah okay
Knight e4 do it for now Knight takes c3
rook takes d8 one of my rook stakes d8
don't tell me don't tell me this Queen
SEC works shame on you
I mean Bishop b3 they're cool like we're
you Queen us to go somewhere I go is
your take see if they're up t1 check
first and Bishop takes c3 and then
actually a boatload of compensation
thanks napoleon dynamite
oh my gosh okay hammer has something
else in mind perhaps because of those
types of variations still a lot for
black to figure out here though Robert
even if II four didn't work is now now
e4 and if you take C 3 you can just take
back with the b-pawn right or take the
Queen now honestly I think II four is is
yeah this is bad this looks just pretty
straightforward and despite the the
minute on the clock
eric is just ya shakin who said there
he's like why did I play Bishop to e6
yeah Eric someone who just said this
song goes Vergil 85 so eric is just
baiting him but nah I think so yeah this
is a mistake filled game isn't white up
a queen for just a rock in a pond well
you are better at math than me so I'm
gonna take your word for it
Queen for Brooke and upon seems accurate
watch black not lose this I'd be
unbelievable no there's just no way do
you think hammer would cry if he didn't
win this position probably not on camera
but later yes because I know hammers got
a teddy bear next to his bed and all
that stuff but I wanted to bring up
something we haven't talked a lot about
of course we are always working on new
and fun ways to cover chess and try to
provide you with a little we'll call it
chess 38 5 38 action here you've got a
live match in progress graph chart kind
of showing you who's predicted to win
this has been a back and forth affair we
ran some analytics Robert on last year's
speeches championship as we've as we
tried to figure out how we can predict
games and matches in real time and the
best match last year was the matchup
between Wesley so and onigiri which
literally I mean it was like it was it
would be like watching a basketball game
but 25 lead changes right but here we
can see despite Hansen being the
favorite on paper this is a pretty close
match both sides on a trajectory right
now we don't have Hanson as as big of a
favor on paper and bullet at least I say
we meaning our our analytics our stats
we'll see if that holds true right now
right now this is a pretty close match
so we'll keep an eye on that on what the
graph tells us because people are graphs
do you don't you love graphs with colors
I love graphs of color storage I want
some pie charts bar graphs some Venn
diagrams give me everything in here but
you know what's go ahead no I was gonna
say makes sense of this about level and
the predictions and the progressions are
seemingly level because you know they
keep trading off victories with the
white pieces and crazy drawers and
things that are happening but right now
hammers up a queen for a rook and pawn
and he's forcing the issue here Erik is
you know interesting match strategy
member in a lot of the the traditional
SCC matches there is a point sometimes
in playing out games that are lost
positions because if you believe you're
better and the bullet time controlled
you take more time off the total running
clock right for those who you've never
watched a main event you'll you know
those matches start at the end of July
but okay I was gonna say there's not
really lot of point in playing out a
lost position in this format Robert
because the game numbers are set it is a
fixed set of five games in five minute
five games in three minute and then ten
games and bullets so playing out that
game wasn't really that useful for Eric
other than just to vent his emotional
frustration yep yeah as long as he's not
throwing chairs we're happy with Eric
and how he wants to vent his emotional
frustration yeah you know it's like he
was saying smaller he's like leaning
back more and more he's looking younger
and younger he's turning into Benjamin
Button on his hand and Amber's leaning
in more I'm getting more and more of a
view to that beautiful perm he's got
going on there I'm just kidding hammer
doesn't permit hair it would be
hilarious I think he should what do you
think Magnus would say if hammer just
showed up like to training camp with a
perm I don't even know if that's a
possible thing I mean yes alright so
right now Queen takes g3 is a threat so
Eric better not overlook that any play
to e3 yeah hmm oh by the way
oh it's for for okay never mind I was
gonna say something about the score not
being leveled but it is four to four and
they're actually just precisely even or
two and a half two and a half in the
five minute and now one and a half one
and a half in the three minutes so
they've been completely leveled and Dan
they have a question do you think we're
overestimating Eric's chances in the
bullet or is he really just that much
better I don't think we are because of
just how how much bullet we've seen Eric
play I mean based on what we're possibly
able to make a guesstimate on I mean
Eric has held his own against some of
the best bullet players on the planet
and he plays a lot more bullet on chest
comm regularly bullet not necessarily
hammers favorite giant which one but
then again hammers been hosting his own
stream where he does blindfold bullet
which is about as insane as I don't even
know what you know some ridiculous
reference I don't know I mean buddy here
so hammer has been pushing himself I
think to improve his bullet status but I
I think it's fair to say Eric is
definitely the favorite yeah I was
actually playing Eric at like 2:30 in
the morning I was lying for my phone and
we're playing some bullet
and I think we went about even eight he
got plus one against me but it just
always reminds you that Meijer is the
guy who just dominates me in online
chess I feel like his record against me
online is a cluster or something it's
just you see well you're not alone in
that department a lot of people feel
that way against Georg Meier I just was
told that it would be very positive and
beneficial for me to kind of air out my
feelings so I just wanted to talk about
how one side of that that matter has
been what do I want what else you want
to talk about I want to talk about
blacks position on a3 I was good about
to mention he wouldn't be three as soon
as I was trying to get that a pawn got a
little too frisky big for his own
britches as parents from the 1950s used
to say this is just terrible for black
you're just down upon so yes what was he
doing by rushing on I don't have any ex
White has the pawn and the compensation
here
yep the two bishops b5 creating pressure
opening up a threat on f8 I mean you
could even take on c6 you don't really
want to help your opponent develop ever
you kind of like the bind but I was just
looking at the b v square that opens up
to the knight on c3 and okay there's
even moves I'm looking at here Robert
like f4 maybe yeah I mean f4 they're
convinced to take on c6 by night b5 yeah
because there's tactics here everybody
here capes if you can get away with
something like this is to show you what
we're looking at so there's there's all
kinds of problems here I'm not exactly
sure him or let the excitement of that
last one get to my thing cuz that a pawn
just was out of control it's an
interesting decision to play b6 yeah I
think he's just gone for the clamp now
yeah not a bad thing to get the clip but
I don't know I guess I trusted I trusted
in the tactical ideas of keeping the
tension here maybe more and I don't like
that I've made it easy for black to both
have a file pressure and get this knight
on b8 back in the game from a 6 to c5
yeah I'm gonna go 594 at some point soon
and you're not gonna be a happy camper
really is it that good for way I guess
my be six point is hanging isn't it he
five night f2 d7 threatening my be sick
yeah
and Elliott out again like what I was
highlighting I mean now black has the
ability to kind of unwind here and this
eight pond is under fire i really i
really don't i'm skeptical of this this
whole approach that eric chose here
yeah the bishop on g2 is not super happy
so may ruck f3 but that's a sad movie
play yeah rook-a three black can trade
get back like getting the pieces out
there's also quit d8 in some positions
if you play rook f3 i'll just defend the
rook maybe poke at the b6 pawn you have
a good point there whoa Knight d5 we
weren't even looking at that move okay
it's an obvious movie had to be
calculating everybody because it
unleashes a discovered attack and
threatens to for connie seven so shame
on us for not seeing that coming but I'm
still not sure black doesn't have a
little bit of compensation here you know
it's funny just there's so many pieces
defending the d5 square we just I just
an oversight I really didn't even come
close to considering it waist like a
Knight takes e4 Queenie 495 what just
happened yeah was there an opportunity
there take take shake-and-bake is their
main the thank you to king gambits for
subscribing which which problem ember
everybody if you are a prime member so
is your twitch prime sub right doesn't
yeah I think Eric is gonna get this one
but the tactics there were questionable
just say the least by both sides
yeah the crooks come in a c8 very
shortly or you can your bish and play b7
right inside even necessary to throw the
rope down
yeah this is not pleasant so they deep
95 was such an obvious like you said
obvious move that didn't even come to
mind was just it's one of those little
oversights I'm guessing hammer also
missed it because otherwise he wouldn't
have put his work on be true yeah oh
wait taketake will be tuned then no it's
not
Brooksie seven there still has to be
enough here oh just go and rook b3 look
at you very nice cut off the Brooks
protection of the queening square not
enough time for black to create tricks
with the Knights he'll give checks to
his heart's content I think roughly
three comes anyway don't even bother
with the d5 pawn yep oh yeah they're
nice little fork to bring the game to a
close just for kicks and giggles but
that's nothing but a fancy way to let
your opponent get a queen and then
likely resign here game set match okay
well not necessarily match yet Eric
Hanson regains the lead everybody takes
a full point there shout out to
everybody who's with us holding strong
roughly 2,500 of you have been here for
the better part of the last couple hours
and we have a match so it'll be
interesting to see obviously every one
of the players that play in these
matches are our very strong grandmasters
Robert and we are sometimes surprised by
how good a player is in bullet so if
it's a close match we'll see if Hamrick
and surprise knows but right now it
looks like Hanson is showing why he was
the 1 seed in this knockout qualifier
and favored in the event yep so I'm just
reading some of the chests just to catch
up on this ya know it's uh right right
now Hanson everything when his way in
that game the hammer movies pawn to a3
was just crazy that's like it's
something that I see when I play one
minute with no increment yeah you either
I do
my opponent does is and would push Harry
and up the board and then they lose the
pawn and it but you know yeah right it
was made no sense she out out to
practical chess for throwing us your
twitch prime love we appreciate it yeah
no that was just a weird game and like I
said I think sometimes the the start of
the next game can be affected by the
hangover you haven't quite shaken off
yet from the previous game and that's
just it's a thing you always have to be
careful of in these quick matches where
you're playing dozens of games you know
you're the emotional hangover is real
even though both the sequels to the
hangover movie franchise were horrible
yeah and I heard that the you know we'd
say shake it off right like the haters
gonna hate hate hate did I just drop an
inadvertent t-swift I think you might
have inverted t-swift
alright okay well this is a new one we
haven't seen this particular opening or
this particular structure at all yet
well we're getting sort of a the
staircase pawn structure right if well
especially if white goes like f5 at some
point you get the the staircase yeah
there it is
there it comes and actually was just on
Netflix last night there's just you know
there's a show called staircase and I
really want to see it but here I get the
other version the chest version yeah and
the thing about this is that white is
trying to gain space on the kingside
eventually perhaps double works in the F
file open the F file up by taking on g6
and using that's his advantage now what
Hansen just did was sacrifice a pawn on
the queenside hoping to get some open
files for his major pieces downside
about that is you have to actually spend
some time using your pieces on the that
need to protect the king side or might
need to protect the king side to
actually start making progress over on
the Queen side so for example is Bishop
on h6 in order to get the a to pawn you
know how to take that 90 which nobody
wants to part with the dark square
Bishop here exactly you definitely want
to do that that 97 is in big trouble now
because it defends the c5 pawn and now F
takes G 6 is a brutal threat with a
bishop on h3 aiming at the knight on
d7 so already I think there are problems
here for blacks I don't
shareable at all because f takes you six
now is welders right yeah well there is
the outside possibility he actually
takes on f5 given that the e4 pawn is
pinned okay now he wants to bring the
rook back into a more defensive position
both guarding the knight here and
indirectly defending things over on the
Kings side but I agree with you it feels
like White has the pawn bat Black has
sort of a bad Banco gambit here and and
white is still kind of in control of
what opens up and when I like this move
a4 and then Bishop a3 just sort of not
even because you're really gonna take
the pawn on c5 Robert but just cuz you
eliminate the threats of the a to pawn
get your Bishop on a better square and
maybe now you can start rethinking about
opening up the Kings side you know the
bishop on e3 has more bark than bite
it's just it looks menacing it takes
away the g1 Square from the King yep it
can't be attacked very easily but the
same time what's its real future it can
take on c1 at any moment but as we
discuss that gets gets the dark squares
hands them right to white and I'm
surprised I was just about to recommend
perhaps rook f3 first to kind of build
on that tension before you open up the
file but what is what does hammer see
here he's just going for this straight
up simplification of winning the c5 font
I think so there you go that's what he
sees answered by a horseshoe hammers
hungry and he says feed me and that's
what he's hammered now watch out 92 runs
right into night 64 game over so that's
the great thing was especially 3 if
Knight 64 happens for example the Queen
if your Queen just gives one check
that's game over
so I actually liked your rook f3 idea
way more than yeah and hammer shaking is
said no III you know we'll jump over to
the analysis here shout-out to Dan the
maestro who just subscribed with his
twitch Prime we appreciate that but I
think this may end up backfiring cuz now
look at Hanson's pieces coming to life
two extra pawns don't mean a whole lot
right now and it's just an interesting
point to remember when you hold all the
cards in a particular pawn tension
building up on that tension is usually
the right idea because then when you
break through often more powerful things
follow so it'll be interesting to see if
hammer can still get
this one okay those pawns are getting
going now yeah there might be an
exchange sack just to take and you know
take a an a5 and take on c5 but I
wouldn't do that quite yet
I like he's from Bishop g5 threatening
night to e3
agreed an important question is if white
is able to sacrifice in exchange if need
be and still be better because the past
pawns in the Queen side I like what
hammers doing enough for sure this rook
enough to could swing over to the Queen
side via a2 and b2 yeah yeah now all of
whites pieces are in turn I'm hoping to
life but don't underestimate that there
is this outside chance that White's King
falls into a mating net and I know
that's what Eric is thinking King f7
potentially opens up the H file so
Hansen's kind of all-in on on getting
something against this king before
White's pollens get too much further up
the board yeah now nice things d4 is a
threats that's why he went g5 you can
always consider rook takes no yeah I was
just about to say I like that I did too
but yet not quite yet these pawns are
hard to stop so rook takes a rook takes
something exactly in exchange I feel
like as necessary there he goes
takes it's gonna come before which both
indirectly defense b5 and threatens
Knight takes e5 but rook be one now
right just okay yeah even better just
get the rook behind the pawn in now now
lady baby Knight b7 yep the good move if
work a seven-night da check oh oh he had
98 96 okay doesn't find is as good a one
but he's still gonna be in control here
yeah only six seconds for Hanson okay
one no no not working one there's a word
I wanted to go Brooke c1 but I realize
my rook gonna be hanging on see once I
can't do that Knight
okay you should still have enough to use
that be pawn to win the game yeah he
doesn't have enough time to defend
anyway 95 check rookie a than any order
pick your flavor that's what you're
telling me flavor flav leyva Flav game
over well hammer ties it up hammer using
the chips brah mojo of pushing baby
against against Eric Hanson stealing one
out of Yaz's book there that be pawn
this is a great well eighty-five Porsche
Turbo in the chest accomplished TV
checkups hammer is a little bit boo-boo
from Yogi Berra type you know he does he
just has a great lovable demeanor about
him and hammer is a total sweetheart if
you've never met him
but yet it was another another fun
comment earlier in the chest TV chat
that I didn't have a chance to say cuz
we were we were focused on the chest but
there does seem to be more hammer fans
on chest TV diamond member super chess
machine triple espresso those guys
seemed to be to be a show in their love
for hammer in the chat yeah and hammer
is really putting up a great fight and
even in this bullet I mean I don't like
repeating the same openings over and
over again especially if you think you
are the better bullet player you need to
mix it up right because by doing this
hammers move instantly he's out 15
seconds on the clock this is a bullet
game with a one-second increment which
is huge yeah I don't underestimate that
I know from up from my point of view
every time I play in arena kings or
wherever and I'm playing bullet I could
definitely use an extra second after
every move to save myself from a good
time trouble so here it Eric goes forth
f4 the idea is very straightforward if
you take on that for I'll take with the
bishop and I developed my piece and a
taxi seven at the same time 95 is a
great response if I'm white I wish my
rook were already on f1 so I could take
on e5 and play Knight f6 check now c6
kicks it and the nice coming back to f5
an IG six of course shuts down the G
file and if you you don't want to really
want the bishop on f4 in many ways
because the knight on f5 is a better
piece than the bishop on f8 but at some
point soon black Inklings c5 as well and
just like trying to open there it is c5
opening the bishop oops now I can take
on a4 take on c5 with check my bishop
breathes new life so this is looking
pretty nice from black okay I'm not sure
about this particular move water I would
have taken on f4 first because now I
like this line about five but 997 should
be played
we're gonna find out really quickly if
we overestimated Eric's advantages and
bullet here here he's down on time and
not really with an advantage and any
kind of advantage to speak up so man I
know I asked you heading into the 3-1 if
I said the match was tied beforehand you
would be you would be saying yeah I
could say that but would you still think
the match to it was gonna be tied headed
in a bullet that this is really where
Eric Hanson flexes his muscles I I you
know I was under the impression that he
was the better bullet player but right
now I'm not seeing that of course is the
first game and they're still playing
game left in this first game but here
just King f7 for example yeah
the Hammers playing perfectly the
Hammers playing perfectly he's he's also
playing confidently he seems to have
found himself after a couple of really
tough losses if you're just joining us
everybody so we got a tied match I'm
excited I'm excited yeah hammer camp
blunder that 95 he's got to be careful
here
kingi seven but this is the kind of this
is the kind of King walk you may regret
in a bullet game cuz yeah you just put
your king in the middle of the fire he
takes in Knight of 75 yeah I know right
after he did it Eric shook his head he
knew it way up you know check rook do a
21 check is game over followed by Queen
2 G 1 and then rook t3 check-ins keep
giving checks yeah music is is not happy
here along with all the chef's bra fans
around the world buckle up everybody we
got 10 games of bullet where the big
favorite on paper has his work cut out
for him down a game officialy is
Grandmaster Eric Hanson and the jackets
coming off the jacket is coming off and
hammer is focused Robert this is what I
was saying I mean everyone kept saying
Hanson is a much better bullet player
but I played both of them and I think
honestly my playing with Hanson last
night where I was on my couch playing on
my phone and I think he said he might
have a plus-one it was a pretty close
bullet match not that I wasn't impressed
he's a great bullet player and I've been
playing much better on my phone as of
late but yep he didn't impress me in the
same way that some other people do I
mean of course Nakamura is a different
animal all together but even the way
George Meyer sometimes just like really
shocks me by how accurate the pinpoint
accuracy I think that hammer is
capable of holding his own now there are
nine games left in this whole apportion
hammer up one has the white pieces in
this game he's doing a very flexible
structure here yep boy it sure takes b1
was just missed it should be one repeat
one was it was missed by Hanson and this
is this is the issue I think Eric needs
to get a hold of his motion so he can
continue to be unbiased and and ruthless
right he's he just missed the tactic
everybody Bishop takes me one would have
eventually allowed him to get the rook
on the first rank with a dominating
position
yeah and he's still better and he's up a
lot of time the jacket did come off
Robert Erika's Erika's he's owned in
here Bishop b2 is a very good move by
hammer because you have to just give up
this G pawn to get your development in
now you're equal material still the
knight could not develop the detour c3
other men in g5 s little awkward
actually I think that pitcher shakes his
head but he got away with one already so
he should be happy but Bishop e2 is a
good move threatening Knight f3 check
and if you take on d8 rook takes the a
Brook take C and I see 3 9 f3 check
nobody has just King H one little KH one
might be the night but then Knight takes
d5 92 verb d2 and the activity is very
good for black okay I mean still it's
not a hundred percent clear yet right
hammers trying to calculate all those
variations as quickly as he can right
now we're gonna find out he's got to
take I think you should take on a three
and play King H to the g3 as quickly as
possible okay but king of c4
yeah shout-out to chest Bey gifting her
65th subsea she is officially greater
than the chessboard chess bait comes
through with her 65th gifted sub at our
chest Channel thank you ma'am
Bishop to g3 okay so hammer does prevent
h4 and he may go for your plan
eventually if king h2 to get out but
Hansen okay
Hansen tries to play h4 and hammer says
no puts the stop on it the little time
situation yeah four seconds for hammer
just now rook da threatening rook d1
check gives him to me this is where
Hansen's at its best you know Hansen is
is not playing as best just when when
he's overthinking things
you know I hate to say this way what
he's trying too hard pull it to play
good chess moves these are the kind of
positions where I feel like if he if
he's trusting his intuition you see him
play bullet with the best in the world
yep now I see eight
what did he just wander that he did he
did now he's gonna be the one I feel
like take 97 take any sounds right away
and then if he gets under five seconds
here but the obstacle Bishop nature of
this position I don't know like what
hammer did either but he's got no time
so it's alright no time at all although
he is gonna get his King out which is
really key
no more mating net for black on the
light squares no more mating up a really
weak a pond so I would play I just go
Bishop c4 played b5 I would play for F
384 if I was hammer he's really taking
his time with that idea but played b5
you have to do it like the thing it
oughta watch for F 384 if your hammer
okay here we go I'm gonna draw which is
hilarious yes I'm black in a classical
game I'm never accepting a drum but here
from last point of view you just need to
start maneuver your piece as well so go
like worke for trying to get the beat
whoa look at this he may end up getting
the black King in a mating net yeah
Hanson had to take it because of the
threat of f5 check that's classy FSS
falling and suddenly hammer is in
control Hansen's the one down on time no
he blunders the e4 pawn yeah but b5
singing take me five you might win over
late I was like king of six there first
but yeah okay riff I've drawn the spot
BAM then he holds king of four with
increment it's over Wow a draw a save
I'm not sure if he'd played King of six
there Robert I'm not sure that hammer
doesn't win that game in a time scramble
cuz King of six by the way if F for
rookie 7 check picked off the bishop I
think that's actually a really good
point I think white actually I think I
think hammer had his mind made up he
wanted to draw that because he's
protecting his one-point lead but I
think he could have won that yeah with
the darks for Bishop he covers HS square
which is the Queen's score that was a
really good fine King of six and it kind
of does emit some similar to the endgame
earlier we're here to go III yeah F
takes me four and just kind of bring the
King into info straight so oh man either
way look at this man we only have we
have eight games left in this match
remember everybody it is a set it is a
set system of 10 games in bullet here
and hammer currently has the one game
match lead with eight games to play
got out to all the diamond members I
feel like ever since I said that more
and more hammer fans are coming out unco
7 super chess machine carpe Noctem the
they're pretty excited here but the the
chess bra the chess brought army is
strong in the twitch chat three
thousands of you are here thank you for
being here I would see Georg Meier
hanging out in the game chat like within
the live game there he's saying
Dominguez will be good in 1 1 2 you'll
see so he's giving props to his opponent
to be in just a little while now
saying that after linear didn't one of
the world blitz once Chris shook said he
never saw one saw someone that fast over
the board yeah look at that respect by
Meyer for Dominguez you gotta respect
gotta respect any any form of world
blitz champion but no Dominguez for as
you and I you remember you and I talked
about this when we said that Dominguez
Perez has tried to qualify his way into
the SCC for a few years now but we said
that if he could ever make it he might
be the kind of guy that could upset one
of the top GM's in the world right cuz
Dominguez Perez is just he's played with
them before so if he can get in after
today he may have his chance and I
barely considered an upset because rush
how much respect I have for Dominguez of
Famer 2760 and current 27 30 40 player
but ok back to this game here
well what's going on here so black is
trying to go tonight h3 check takes at
four of white if because II for now
isn't that Bishop trap so TAS achenes of
f3 no he doesn't I thought maybe he had
what you choose falling this looks
really oh why is it Odell the rook on d8
okay so II to Brooke takes d8 and then
in Brook takes D a queen East seven hits
both what their tactics like F threes
coming here if Knight takes the eight f3
here he goes left to f3 rook f2 there
was okay yeah you're right there's no I
thought there might be like some weird
night h3 check or something but I think
you're right I think that it's all a
bluff by hammer will it work with Hansen
only having ten seconds nice over
Queeny for he's not giving up yet
there's still some outside Queen g49 age
three tactics that Hansen has to be wary
of okay he's going 494 two is now good
94 is coming next followed by change 97
check oh you know what he's wearing 97
check them now 94 hit ah wait 95 to
still not enough though Queen ephors a
nice way to keep the tension hitting the
night by 5 but I think Hansen's
defending I agree and with only 4
seconds he's defending well look at that
one point 2 seconds on the clock amber
did that's awesome
but he's completely losing the only way
you win this is a pre move blunder and
time scramble everybody but otherwise
Hansen will bring the match level with 7
games to go we're in for a dogfight
don't go anywhere thanks to all 3000 of
you who are with us you can see the
tension on their faces yeah it's even
now wow I mean I'm just trying to even
bring my head in closer to get a better
look at some of the stuff going on here
but look at Eric's time he's a 2 seconds
left so yeah he's hammer III that's why
I had a reaction just a moment ago you
missed I thought I thought he was
forgetting about his clock but ok
doesn't look like he is no and he's he's
too fast right now he's gaining 0.3
seconds every move just so easy you're
gonna primo a bunch of things as soon as
you can start pre moving checks as well
the advantage is just easy in these
types of games so should be enough
hammer doing the right thing playing it
out because you never know in any bullet
setting but this should be one that that
Hansen wins going away and we haven't
even match mate on the board I'm bored
ok well this is just I mean this is this
is either players match right now and if
you were if you told hammer beforehand
you know take your chances with a coin
flip and bullet I mean you'd have to
he'd have to take it I think you know
given given Hansen's reputation of being
the stronger player so at least as far
as blitz and rapid goes I wouldn't
necessarily say that answer is stronger
than Hammett I think they're what are
these two players peak fidei ratings by
the way somebody in chat probably knows
that I think hammer was near 27 good as
a hamp hammers the stronger OTB player
as far as both of the
peak performances but you could also
argue that hammer plays more than then
Eric does these days yeah I'm not really
convinced there's a tremendous
difference
OTB between these two players I think
that they are of the fork playing that I
think they're the lowest two of the four
but that doesn't mean anything when
we're talking about what is going on
with the c-4 square so you have to play
Bishop d5 as was played by hammer but
this is not the ideal setup for white
with your bishop on d5
yeah if you can work his way out of it
he'll be happy because he was shaking
his head there something clearly went
wrong but maybe he ends up with some
more Queen side pressure than he thought
he would get yeah watch out for Bishop
a7 Bishop e7 am Bishop e6 or both on the
docket so habit c5 yep there's the five
this is suddenly White's pieces have
it's like he planned it the Queen and
Bishop battery is nice here and and the
piece is facing toward the Queen side
here comes a rook to see one I assume
yeah quickly plays and I'm like a ninety
ninety four or even back up the bishop
and try to use the d5 square yeah I like
that even better Bishop comes back here
comes the d5 square Danny sometimes you
suggest really good moves every once in
a while buddy one for every one of your
ten Bishop h1 was a sweet move I really
respect them that's uh here comes Bishop
e6 and he can even slide over to a3 at
some point and kind of poke at the pawn
with the Queen there on liking and that
night watch for Knight f4 was a little
Bishop c7 Queen things b7 wasn't isn't
that pawn Hong and somebody minute yeah
would have been even better okay he goes
for the Queen h4 yeah I think he should
have played Queen a3 before we're
treating the knight to keep the Knight
f4 option open but who don't miss f6
yeah okay this is the game that feels
like hammer is is in control of and
Hansen is struggling to deal with all
the tactics we'll see if he can do it
with less than 20 seconds yeah he
couldn't take on e4 because Knight f6
checked in out f4 should be good for
white as well and you're the word the
bishop c7 just keep staring at us
look at this movie he's just relocating
the bishop around rook takes c6 wasn't
that positive led bishop before after oh
we missed it you're right he may win
this game anyway but that's a nice fine
rook takes c6 and Bishop before would
have been a skewer everybody of the dark
squares yeah
and too good to be true it's a queen d3
is coming yes just one the exchange so
straight up this should be pretty
straightforward for him right anyway
Bishop takes d6 was possible and then
queen a3 but he doesn't go for it
yeah I think he's just gonna play simple
chess now it's not like you can go d5
anytime soon with the bish when I've
three so yeah just just play just don't
worry too much Bishop III and now Bishop
back to g2 yep he's going 95 but that's
just it's not really a big threat anyway
man oh man if hammer wins this game a
full point lead with only six to play
Henry clock management is awesome as
well looking at me yeah no he's playing
bullet-like
like he knows what he's doing okay for
that to sound but we just had such a
such a preconceived thought that the
bullet would be a runaway train for mr.
Hansen and it's not proving to be that
way look at this he's just he's playing
high-quality technique here trusting his
instincts brings the king up around to
f4 he's gonna create new avenues for the
rooks to get in that's what you do when
you're up the exchange kids trade open
up things look at this he's gaining time
on the clock just positionally grinding
opening up principle of two weaknesses
can the flankers rolling over in his
grave
rook c7 checked wanted to be some good
b5 just do it he's winning either way g4
is a move now he finds it take on d5
rook takes h5 oh okay not letting me do
that
no way Eric's being resourceful here
it's kind of tricky stuff going on take
on h5 give me that pawn yeah this is
over no but you're right I mean it's
Fela it feels like hammer it's been over
for a while I think it still is but Eric
did did make this a little bit trickier
than we thought it would be yeah motion
her as long as a bull game is still
going there's always a chance so nice
defensive maneuver there to get the
Bishop to d7 absolutely
what did they yeah this is some people
do not like the fact that hammer plays
on until mate when he's losing I don't
mind it at all I mean it's just his
right as a chest that didn't go well for
hammer right there yeah what's going on
here lost that H punt for no no
compensation and and he's not even
better anymore nice for the 94 would
have had a meeting net on be to
everybody camera let this one get away
for sure it was it was over Red Rover
and now anything could happen because
it's three seconds four seconds tell me
you wouldn't favor the night in this
type of position right yeah nights are
too strong and it's really not only is
it the night that I favor start liking
black solution the 27 is a really
good different you know that was a
really nice maneuver when he found that
okay Hammer hammer breaks through
winning to be five but that was huge
that works
yeah the rooks are back to being favored
now but still that night is so strong
whoa one time I like you know there's so
many changes in the actual game that I
stopped looking at the clock for a
second and that's when Hanson flag he
looked in disbelief and did you see
hammers face someone better have clip
that oh because G Yammer is doing that
movie it's like you know it's shaking it
out because he's stressed we have a
battle going on in the twitch chat
between hammer time emotes and chess bra
for the boys banter but either way we
think all three thousand you for being
here remember that prize fund is donated
by all of you we appreciate all of your
support and it goes directly to the
players all four of them playing today's
speech has championship knockout
qualifier so if you like what you see
let them know share the love and thanks
to everybody for your support and for
being here I cannot believe we're in a
position where hammers up a game and boy
I am I am shocked right now because I
just think you know I can believe it I
was unquestioning the whole time I were
I you get credit for kind of saying hey
are we being a little you know in
fairness I think you did also pick
Hansen but you know didn't you yeah I
did
I thought Hansen was you know I just
thought that he was a slight favorite
but he also had a lead since game nine
it was conquista forges winning a piece
right a second ago
it was we queens before hit the bish one
c5 and then the nine and c6 behind it so
Hanson not in his prime form right now
but he's really not everybody in this
position here there was a well I'm just
gonna go back to the live position there
we go
anyway yeah Eric almost came back and
either water drew that last one but the
truth is before that time scramble we
were you know we've been we've been much
more impressed with hammers play today
in Bullitt I mean III think that that's
the fair thing to say
yeah well though right now I'm not
really impressed in this position yeah
we have right now this is this is
White's game all over it ooh great
decision though to a nice seat to d6 you
don't block a the D file make sure now
he's in the worse is now behind him Eric
a little frustrated with that shakes his
head but he's still 10 seconds then if
he can read okay I was gonna say maybe
move the bishop back open up the D file
and try to bring the knight in to f5
Queen d7 whoa that can't be good Bishop
b5 Bueller Bueller yeah I love it now
Bishop c4 with tempo now night eight oh
I can't go nice what you for singing
okay so c5 is not hanging his f7 are you
gonna add a green and highs a jack our
last two subs really appreciate it so
watch out when you have 7 square doesn't
say Queen e2 is a ooh c6 takes Bishop I
said it first
yep you did no it's okay he does fight
it Danny we missed an even better move
rook takes d7 was better oh my gosh it
was crushing
okay I'll pull up the analysis even
though it's bullet just to show
everybody the brilliant tactic that my
partner just saw in this position we saw
c6 rook takes d7 Queen takes Den c6 was
even better winning two pieces for the
rook because the pawn is poisoned
due to winning the Queen that would have
been a brilliant fine there but I think
Eric is gonna get this game anyway buddy
yeah he's got two pieces for the rook so
it ended up being in a similar boat but
now blacks King has no shelter the
Queen's come is c4 and d5 of check f4 is
always a good move to reinforce tonight
the Queen's off the board favors black
telford that was a huge win for black
what just this is not ideal this is not
ideal at all everybody because you know
you've got to miners working with the
Queen you want to get going over there
against the against the king now this is
where the rooks potentially thrive I
think the two pieces are still better
but with a passed pawn this is this is
not as easy for Eric as it was Bishop d4
though now his lights out yeah g7 is a
problem and black doesn't have an answer
he will lose no he doesn't he thought he
would lose on time but Brooke h7 game
over Knight a5 smooth quickly 905 rook
over to c7 only three seconds on the
clock though okay chill still just
should be over any moment d1 rook do you
know it doesn't quite work unfortunately
flag okay well you know like laughs game
regardless of the time scramble the
person who deserved a win kind of did I
mean chess karma is a funny thing but
Eric played well that game and he takes
it even if it got a little messy in the
end oh man oh man here we go both sides
nervous we have five games left first
player to ten-and-a-half is gonna win
this match everybody if you do the math
in 20 games ten and a half wins unless
okay unless they each have ten points
and they draw that game so okay I again
my math fails me man
should the state in school well you know
there are your five games left they can
tie 10/10 and then we have overtime
right so let's keep going yeah but
hammer with the white pieces now trying
to play for an advantage in the Senate
right typical grünfeld
black gets or the D pawn and had White's
lost beep on though indirectly because
what black plays c3 and you know White's
white supplanted to continue and
pressing in the center now a2 is hanging
with tempo but if you take eight to work
a1 Fischer has to go back to e6 or to c4
and you don't really want the bishop on
c4 because D takes d5 removes the guard
and if you go back to sixth and d5 we've
seen that idea before we've seen this
and we get d5 again
Timothy Connolly needs a hug some
buddy give Timothy Connelly somebody
hold him so Bishop a4 so how do you go
Queen e2 just take away the c-4 square
oh then I hang d5 wait how does
something happen incorrect for hammer
here yeah he's he's losing the d5 pawn I
don't see you can't sit with an Ikea
taking the night oh wait then I know
rook d1 there's also East six okay
East six is gonna be punched through at
some point and with it whoa
maybe compensation but man that is an
aggressive Queen down there and I like
it
why can't Hanson just gobble up these
pawns I think he can he's gotten away
with it hammers the one who's going into
the think tank he's gonna be explaining
to bullet the bullet scrambled now gonna
try to make a mating net out of nothing
over here on the Kings side to justify
his destroyed Queen side he may get it
dude that's why it's a bullet gambit cuz
sometimes it works when there's no time
on the clock here he goes yeah he's
actually getting huge compensation now
because the Queen and Knight team up
very well in the Kings side p.m. at h5u
melee go g4 and blast open the cage 6 e
7 is falling along with h6 and a whole
lot of positions everybody
oh yeah oh you can't tell you can't take
on f7 what you want to do to get to set
well maybe because I'm falling at the
end yeah rook f7 e takes down Queen f7
back and then rook takes e7 as you just
mentioned so the Queen h5 working his
way up so he takes with the Queen he's
gonna take a 5 or 7 with check Hansen is
not happy here shaking his head take a 5
it's a free pawn I think he just doesn't
see it sometimes it's an optical weird
trick I think the Queen I don't think
amber realizes the f5 pawn is hanging
Wow like legit I could tell
Wow 4 is kind of a threat but not really
but that could be a game saver right
there
here comes f4 for Hanson hammer just
didn't receive the pawn was hanging Wow
look at Hanson's time 3 second look at
one second he's down he made that move
with 0.6 on the clock this is
unbelievable you just have to get that
rook off 2f file signal Rubeus trapped
on e3 so he has 2 seconds
yes rookie for Queen f7 James Queen of 7
I didn't see that there's c4
cpsc forties winning and he does
the t49 f 694 okay but take on d5 take
on d5 take on d5 and take e7 know he's
gonna settle on the draw he's nervous oh
em gee that was crazy who was winning
there if he tooks there if he takes on
d5 there was Queenie one check so he was
right not to take it would have been
okay I got it mate yeah oh I think we do
one check and then still a draw but yeah
it's yeah Wow chest chest on Calvin
coming up with a haiku I think it's not
what's a what's a no haiku is 575 right
what's again I should have stayed in
school but some poetry being recited in
the chest TV chad is he roots for hammer
the chest bra fans pretty psyched that
Hansen held onto that one and and I'm
pretty psyched that we only have four
games left and a tied matches pretty
much all you can ask for when you're
looking for exciting chess by super
geum's I think you guys what I would say
people who are not Argentine fans will
be happy that Nigeria even that match up
12 minutes ago I just keep being at the
score so no other goals for Argentina
since Messi's that's what no I'm Victor
Moses tied the game and it looks like
Croatia's beating Iceland so we have fun
times in Russia but in an event that's
features no Russian Russians and still
is about chess we see Hanson hammer
eight eight what is going on in this
game the d4 square is firmly under
control by both parties but why I feel
like white let this get away something
happened to you're out of the opening
cuz you have to like black setup here
he's gonna take on d4 where the piece
just so we can keep the file open
everybody and poke at the d3 pond yeah
b3 things you have to Queen d1 if you're
gonna be a queen is your takes d4 green
takes d4 yes no I'm like in hammers
opening here and his time small edge but
rowan Foxley in the chess TV chat says
this is the best match since nakamura
Fabiano I'm not even sure that that was
really that close of a match but thanks
for the support
so let's see take here Queen how do I
get my Queen the Queen
I can't move my Queen because we would
quit a c7 you take on d4 and if I move
my Queen to somewhere else you take on
b6 I don't give to b6 I would have
considered Bishop to f8 instead of
Bishop to h6 because the bishop FA tax
upon them before mission H does prevent
f4 from coming into play here but it
still seemed like I know you're right
and one of the things we highlighted
blacks pressure but the truth is the
queen is also kind of tied down to the
b6 pawn and the d4 Knight so it's it's
not so simple for hammer and here comes
f4 by Hansen as soon as he can get it
he'll play it yes if he'd gone mission
of fate earlier he could put c5 or I
just wish you're famous now he has to be
concerned I have four breaks
he plays f6 now if f4 of on e7 check
just wins to b6 one doesn't it oh wow I
thought I said but in the T 3.0 yeah
yeah oh you're right
it's a B 595 whose piece on the edge is
worse here in this case it might
actually be the bishop that's worse than
the night because of the c6 pawn yeah
Hanson has worked his way out of that
middle game that was very nice feels
like White's in control now GE okay Oh
watch out now you can't take on G Fabio
f5 because an h4 comes but he has bishop
oh I thought he would go from Bishop a5
chicken slide the Queen de - dude I
think Bishop a5 Queen e2 before he all
said wrong move order he should have
went Fred black oh my gosh and hammer
wins the before pawn
wait isn't the night hanging on it yeah
this is all in with the meeting yet now
he I'm telling you Bishop a5 I'll pull
up the analysis board Bishop a5 and
Queen e2 that was that was the call look
at White's clock white has no time black
is in trouble though Queen g3 or quench
with Rickey 5 now then Bishop f5 or
Bishop e6 check this is bad bad news for
hammer Bishop d2 what is try a saving
attempt over it's over
he got Hansen worked his way in
although rook takes f6 it's not totally
over yet Brooks the bishop comes to b3
to save the day the bishop on the
diagonal guarding the G spot but now he
left the pawn go okay but he doesn't
matter
too many pieces to Queens are better
than one he's gonna get made it on the
diagonal and he does
that's bad hammer had this one Wow not
have allowed the H pawn to take on g5
that was a tremendous air issue in g4
before him an h4 lots of mistakes of
course this bullet chest of these
mistakes happen but just I mean crazy
and we have a lot of things happening in
our group call here we can see that the
man waiting to play Nexus now sitting in
Erik Hansen spot because the camera
isn't rated place so that's fun
everybody apologies for that but clearly
that is not the case and oh it's me and
Dominguez are going to Vegas Perez are
on camera there but that's what happens
when you do a lot of production
beforehand so but we're gonna continue
to watch this close match let it
continue to go even though the cameras
are a little bit off oh it's you and
Eric this hilarion that was me and Eric
I tried to change it we I I think I
think we should continue or should we
take a break and figure no breaks let's
go
continue the match I think I'll work on
the tech as best I can but let's not
stop the chess party well it's rolling
you know what's going on how many games
are left there are still three games
left okay and I'm gonna work on fixing
the cameras there right there are three
games left right did I just say that
correctly yes there are three games left
essentially yes yes this is fun
alright Eric and and hammer you can
continue to play whenever you're ready
and I will be doing my best to fix the
show because what happened there
everybody was somebody made a big
mistake but it wasn't us and I'm just
gonna do the best we can to make fun
with it and we're locked into a super
close match here I got to check on the
stats by the way Robert even though I
know you're not on camera it's me and
Eric here look at this this is literally
the definition of lead changes
predictions flopping all over the place
as far as who should win this match so
as much as as much as we could have
bargained for but right now the bullet
favorite with a slight edge here up by
one
so go take it away Robert while I try to
fix this tech here yeah we see a repeat
we've had this opening earlier in the
day and this time instead of hammer
taking on b7 Eve a Bishop g2 right away
and now I think 95 is a better version
than earlier because the Brooke on b8
barreled down to Palm B - without that
being a threat white is able to kind of
carry off blacks ideas a little bit more
easily so c6 take take so now is 95
possible because can follow up with E
for now Queen c4 here instead of Queens
East six might have been the move to
make just preventing white complaint
before to protect that night to cement
its place in the center f5 Wow Queen b3
is a nice move throwing 97 check well it
actually stops running as king f7 can be
followed there so now do you play Knight
f4 you're gonna have to sacrifice one of
your pawns back you can't keep the
material edge maybe Bishop g5 was
possible as well Bishop g5 hit the
Brooklyn da tez night c7 for king queen
and rook Hansen is in for a think here
because queen c6 for the initiative but
now from 98 Queenie for f3 you hit the
Queen on e4 and you to spend time to
recoup this method on a8 so yeah rook d3
played but what move can you make in
response Queen B for defends the e4 pawn
and was played there's there's someone
some definite ideas with back grain
checkmate because black has moved all
the pieces off the back and so here a 5
if the Queen takes e4 F no after you
just take it oh you what is going on
here how you gonna get out of this how
is hammers King gonna find shelter it's
probably not
oh I'm not gonna win an award for how
quickly I just set up video capture that
took me 45 minutes I just fixed in the
three minutes can I get a freaking
applause you're a legend and Hammer
unfortunate the flag and get mated so
something I'm terribly wrong for him
here as I as I saved the match hammer
unfortunately seems to be blowing it and
he will be down two games with only two
left he's literally in the spot where
it's winter go home now Robert yeah
and he's shaking his head and he knows
that he's been he knows is that okay
it's a two-game lead for Hanson it's
been a super close match with back and
forth back and forth play by everybody I
you know wow hammer needs to win so he
goes to the caro-kann he's using the
karo opting for that and a bullet game
and you tailored the Jeep on f6 probably
if Airport take there Eric needs just a
draw from a mistaken so if Eric Hansen
makes a draw he in fact wins this match
against all he needs is a draw Unova
comma so it seemed like a weird choice I
think when you have to win but at this
point black just has to create tension
and and then cross his fingers and and
pray you know that there's some sort of
winning chances given to him yeah often
you don't need to have the most pressing
openings in bullet you just need to be
able to sustain some sort of pressure
and continue the game get a time
advantage and thus far hammer up three
seconds in the clock doesn't sound like
a lot right a three seconds actually a
quite a big deal now it's seven eight
nine seconds and here 95 is a threat or
Bishop c5 offering the trade those
bishops first just putting the night at
c5 next from black hitting the e4 pawn
in the Bashan b3 the a4 pawn while it
does take up some space it also can
become a target black it has everything
you could ask for from this opening and
this is how you play for black and so b5
the idea is that if you take them before
we take with a pawn either look eight
one check big check on the board
and now the a5 pawn you really want to
target Knight b7 might just pick up the
pawn there it goes yep a knight back to
c5 you could take them b3 at any moment
the a6 pawn is just just take over
tonight
f5 still covered by the bishop on CA
this is just much better for black up 20
seconds this is unbelievable I mean this
is just pure like technique by hammer
with the black pieces and this this is
impressive honestly by him because he's
lost a bunch of games recently he was in
the driver's seat a little bit a few
games ago
lost a couple and now is trying to
regain his footing and here it looks
like Bishop rook H to d8 then Bishop ei
trade off the Brooks and just be up upon
the 985 covers the e6 square from any
checks wife's not in time play move like
before this is just terrible look at the
time situation too
so play Bishop f7 trade off take this on
b4 play 96 your knight goes that okay
race it doesn't matter I don't think you
should play at five here we're not black
us some time to figure out what he wants
to do but whoa what is that g5 oh wait a
second now this is winning yeah exactly
f5 is a nice move but that was close to
making a draw doing this is hammer comes
through that was close if if black had
captured on h4 and on e4 then the pawns
would have prevented the what the black
king from entering and then the white
king could go from b4 to a five
back-and-forth and claim a draw so that
was very very close so now we have
hammer with the white pieces he needs to
win again he's been getting good
positions with the white pieces so
hopefully for him and his fans that he
can keep it going and so far huge
spatial advantage for white got the
pawns of efore and d4 black has gained
some queen sized space as a pawn to a4
but that pawn can be a target as much as
it is a strength and so now Bishop g4 is
played to attack the d4 square so note D
five okay you compromise your pawn
structure just by Bishop e2 now white
can play f4 in the near future tonight
goes to C for the bishop can always drop
back to the C 1 square and the Knights
are just can Bob delay they're stepping
on each other's toes be it as c4 and b6
now this is already looking Pleasant for
for hammer yeah
would he would he really win two games
going away yeah he's definitely trying
to you know face
he's going to turn f4 f5 and just break
open the G file because he's not casting
this King yet good choice to just from a
must-win perspective I mean this is a
super dynamic unbalanced position Bishop
Air vs. Knights attacking the King side
yeah 19 b6 forces a queen trade 96 96
wait what what is a five-night 65 Queen
64 I guess you're just in time to avoid
any ridiculous discoveries on the
diagonal I think you got to be happy if
your Hansen here you somehow closed off
that attack and much better chances now
rook h3 is a good lift but lift to wear
lifts of nowhere so rook b3 here and ok
route b5 so in a lot of end games
actually it looks like White's pawn
structure is very bad but you have the
outside pass pawn so if you're white you
should I don't know about that why
doesn't say you should play rook deform
bishop d1 and just try to go for the a
pawn now H phones weak yeah I really
think this is the game this might be the
game that that Eric moves on to the
finals so Bishop H 4 F 5 is an idea okay
Bishop h4 f 5 with a discovered attack
got it so now Bishop f3 threatening a5
or fi first to start a Nimbus ref 3 so
if you have five and you take with the e
pawn your d 5 squares weak and you take
keep on age 5 pounds yeah I like that
idea he didn't see it what he's going to
the a pawn I really think yeah he's just
gonna bring that Bishop back around so
Bishop f3 now Bishop a3 Bishop d1 and
Hanson only has 9 seconds left some 54
Czech Bishop e3 good move
whoa but you're looking for that is risk
it to get the biscuit chest that rook
could get trapped there here comes King
about the work and more worried about
White's XA and blacks a for pawn now
that's an outside pass the H bomb wait
okay picture takes a 4 with tempo Knight
63 days can do so doesn't King D 2 here
maybe yeah King did you would have held
the structure together perhaps that was
why that check was rook d7 was missed by
both
okay but he still has the past a pawn
and never in 1357 chat he can't do
anything to stop it candy that was a
great move
so Bishop I would go mmm
there should be three you go after the
e6 pawn okay nice disciplined move their
king c2 actually just a fence III grind
it out now you have f5 or I thought she
would play a five know he's gonna trade
the f1 for the Chi pawn instead if I was
probably better
it's an e6 our check check e six or
something that he's six
check check we see six Brooke if to
check is coming though this is a chef's
e6 and e7 Eric has to Bishop d6 was only
move and so Claybrook it we play Brooke
h7 their first rookie seventh first was
better you're right partner c4 pawn was
hanging so you could just keep the
bishop their work singing flutters the
rook oh my gosh oh my gosh we have a
Tigers Highness to back-to-back blunders
and that was a right match two games won
back to back camera can hardly contain
his nerves so what happens now this is
it
next game wins next game wins next -
sighs unless this is a draw and let's
it's open it's already it already is in
that cuz if somebody wins it's over if
it's a draw then clearly next game wins
Wow okay I thought it would be a best-of
to o-m-g Wow
this could be a huge turning point okay
I mean I was calling I mean Eric won two
games in a row after being tied at eight
all he needs is a single draw and
back-to-back games but hammer comes
storming back the fans are going nuts
thank you to all three thousand of you
who can't go anywhere obviously because
how could you oh man that was exciting
it still is exciting know if I'm white I
were gonna Brooke up a to be one they're
throwing Bishop f7 and that's swinging
my queen over to a two at the right
moment and Knight g5 yeah you can time
this well but Knight g3 now that way
your knight come to f5 and then play
Queen a to Queen
- there's gonna have to be it doesn't
work yet piece of these seven to guard
it if you're just joining us everybody
we are tied 1010 in the first match of
three matches today next game wins we
are officially in overtime in the speed
chess championship knockout
wowsers what a way to start the year hum
buddy we got a lot of these matches this
year this is this is hopefully this is a
sign of things to come
yeah this is exciting we have another
exciting match afterwards I mean I don't
know how they're gonna top this this has
been such an even match if it has there
any I can't even speak it's been so say
have there been any more separation than
one point like I don't like no / - I
mean yeah both sides have led by two
games no no no no Hansen has led by two
games a couple times hammer has only had
a one game lead yeah you're right it was
ten to eight exactly so all right now
pressure on this a five square yep he
takes d4 Knight takes before you just go
Queen Eve five and just plug up that
diagonal if he five here from White
Queen b4 probably is the intermediate
move necessary to hold on to this game
because the bishop on e7 kinetics I
agree but he's calculating cuz this is a
maker of Break It moment right here he's
got he's shaking his head he has to find
some sort of attack here well he
could've just he can just make a draw
yeah he doesn't need to win this game
now he's just losing Knight f8 9 f8 to
e6 Knights are always a very good buck
hater always put the knight on e6 always
blockade Queen d5 there's a battery
hitting the g2 square he says no thank
you
he took that pawn Oh d3 check is
Wednesday check is coming so now Queen
f6 96 to follow d3 check oh do you think
chef one baguette d3 check on the spot
winning the Queen Obi - Erik shakes his
head happy that hammer missed it no no
that was the match there's clear
compensation but not more than that for
white he's worse he's trying to initiate
in the task 6 seconds oh my gosh here
just 53 check this is crazy
look out for tactics on the h3 square
with that Bishop
rocking the long diagonal okay hammer
not gonna get that any more handsome
foots the King on h2 but I just we're
one blunder away from somebody moving on
to the finals today but look at him look
at Eric's clock here he's down on the
clock Hanson has 25 takes into place
quickly and do the d3 post at the same
time this is a pretty easy win for
hammer this is a pretty easy win for ham
or Hanson smiling frustrated right now
but but it's not over yet it's pretty
over nice Knight c3 didn't take up okay
or that I was a knight see Thurman take
on a four yeah but it's it's oh it's
over I mean short of a time scram I
wonder he wants of a night d1 check but
doesn't work no King he - oh he misses
it take on B to take on takes on d8 hey
it's not over yet I mean Hanson isn't
he's a flag oh my God he's just flag but
he moved with just barely enough time on
the clock
oh my gosh I don't think I've ever seen
it happen that way okay unfortunately
it's probably not gonna be enough for
Hanson but oh my gosh wait he just took
another pawn if he draws the match
continues if he draws the match
continues hammer not doing his best job
of ending this match nicely 595 Mingo
Bishop d7 and I take on you oh you can't
commissioner yeah yeah but you go to
gobble up the cheap own it's over no but
what is you're doing you just gave up
the gate for pawn because he didn't want
to lose his g5 on oh man this is close
this is so close because that G pawn if
it's you know they're pieces are capped
you go G for broke a 6 doesn't have any
time to think about it though huge props
to Hanson just for defending says this
far I mean honestly this has been insane
but you know Hanson unfortunate
unfortunately he there not enough time
and he blunders the rook and oh my gosh
thumbs thumbs up
that was a clap Wow was that the best
match in speed chess championship
history
it's a
there it's up there honestly oh my gosh
very possible that we just witnessed the
best match in speech Chess Championship
history yeah I don't even know trying to
unmute both of our of our players here
they're both awesome class acts if the
if I can I will unmute them just waiting
for the opportunity to do so there we go
we have Erik's audio has rejoined us
trying to unmute we're trying to bring
hammer back hammer if you can unmute
yourself not sure if you can hear me
there he is
wow oh my gosh you guys that that could
have been the greatest speech just
championship match we've ever had
straight up
obviously Erik we'll start with you I
know you're you're very just got to be
disappointed right now you had a
two-game lead and it seemed like you
were moments away from clinching this
thing and just what happened take us
through take us through the last series
of games there and what was going on
yeah no I just I just choked I just
choked Danny I got a bit nervous I'm
trying to remember the game when I was
up I was up to but I just didn't control
the nerves I played a really really bad
game you know I just needed a draw and I
I don't know I just I just put a little
rushed
I got a passive position and he and he
converted it pretty well but I just I
just didn't have the nerves today so it
was really back and forth I I have to
still think about what happened I don't
really just going through the motions
but ya know and obviously it's easy for
anybody who's not playing the games to
say so but you know you have you had you
both have huge fan bases here on Twitch
so first of all huge shout out to both
of your fans I mean we've seen a battle
between chess bra emotes and Norwegian
flags and so you guys both delivered
today regardless of who's moving on to
this afternoon's match but hammer what
about you you're down two games to go
you're you're basically you're almost
dead in the water right Erik needs a
half a point and what we're
what were you telling yourself at that
point and how did you keep yourself calm
and focused III didn't want to lose this
match and bullet
I thought arrogance probably a stronger
boots player than I am but I thought I'm
not gonna lose this match in bullet but
I almost did and I ya know I was I was
fortunate to win three in a row at the
end you and I have question for you it
seemed like a lot of fans thought that
Eric was actually the heavy bullet
favorites are you saying that you felt
like you were the Blitz underdog but
could hold your own in the shorter time
control hmm yeah but also one plus one
is a very strange time control it's
something that neither Eric nor I never
play so yeah it was very difficult to
predict how that would turn out well now
that you played it in a match like this
what are your what are your what did you
learn and what will you take with you
into the finals today regardless of
whether you play a gay or admirer or
linear Dominguez Perez what are you what
are your thoughts and it's still chest
it's still chest I feel like Eric made a
mistake in the 1+1 playing the same
openings we had played the the other
games in the March thereby giving me
less to think about because I am prone
to take one thing too many but but I
felt like in the in the bullet games I
was able to to play something I had been
comfortable with in the Blitz games well
then back to you Eric what are your
thoughts on that what were your thoughts
do you have any match strategy coming in
here or or was it just you know you were
just going with the flow and whatever
came view trusting your instincts and
doing it I was mainly going with the
flow I would say that's right I wasn't
getting good positions with with you for
and I kept repeating it that was just
that was just silly it wasn't
necessarily the plan and I was
definitely definitely didn't make the
best opening choices one plus one has
always been a weak time control for me I
think we've like I think we flagged more
on the Blitz than the one plus one and
the especially in Reverse games it was
just just weird like I play a little too
quick when I shouldn't and a little too
slow when
I have to play fast but yeah I didn't I
didn't adjust as well I thought in terms
of like getting good positions I don't
like the positions I got in the book is
at all so yeah I could have done better
there was there was there speaking of
those positions was this just part of
your how much prep if any did you do or
did you just kind of have an idea of
what positions you know you're
comfortable with it seemed that at the
start of the match you won your first
two games is white and that structure
you were getting there out of that out
of that Lopes seemed to be something you
were very comfortable with so so when
did that change oh I think I think you
made the right adjustments there I got a
good position early on he gave me this
five move so I comfortable LightSquared
bishop and afterwards he he he changed
the move order up a bit and and play d5
early on and challenged the center a bit
more which is usually what you're
supposed to do I don't know I'm not too
up-to-date on theory but that's that's a
pretty good way of playing it and his
more aggressive approach in terms of
trading off and challenging the squares
he just stood there and I started to
just not get anything as white I
probably I probably should have switched
a lot sooner well I mean I know you're
being hard on yourself now but the truth
is it was a one game match where you had
a two-game lead so either way you were
it felt like if we had if we had played
three more games here who knows who
would have won right you guys have been
back and forth all day and it was it was
awesome
honestly it was awesome Robert on a few
of any other questions before we take a
small break and let everybody refresh
themselves before we immediately start
the next match but yeah I think I need
me to because I'm looking at my own
webcam and I'm completely red in the
face this match was so intense and I'm
so warm right now I need to I need to
take a shower I think before the final
yo you and I have one quick question for
you before we let you go who do you want
to play in the match who you want the
who do you want to win essentially
between Meyer and Dominguez to see your
next opponent later today well I I feel
like I have had some some interesting
games against
org and also linear is the former world
bullets champion so so I feel like a
matchup against the arena King beast I
would very much like to have Meyer Meyer
being his reputation precedes him now
everybody talks about his domination of
our arena kings but okay honestly this
was this was just amazing so thankful to
both you Eric class-act we know it
didn't go the way you hoped it would but
you were right there and this is
certainly something we'll be doing again
in future years as far as the
opportunity to give somebody a chance to
make the SEC and and on that note you
love big you move on and we will see you
again in a couple hours
we're gonna move on to some some to a
waiting screen here as I try to
frantically try to fix our tech given
some of the stuff that I was have been
band dating for the last three hours and
we're gonna wish Eric and and hammer
goodbye for now no thanks thanks for
having me Danny good luck
you thanks